l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi relatif à l'organisation
de la gouvernance de la sûreté nucléaire
et de la
radiprotection pour répondre au défis de
la relance de la filière nucléaire et du
projet de loi organique modifiant la loi
organique du 23 juillet 2010 relative à
l'application du 5e alinéa de l'article
13 de la
Constitution la procédure accélér a été
engagé sur ces textes il a été décidé
que ces textes feraient l'objet d'une
discussion générale
commune la parole est à madame la
présidente madame Dominique
estrosissasson pour un rappel au
règlement merci madame la Présidente je
souhaite effectivement faire un rappel
au règlement au titre de l'article 42
qui concerne l'organisation des débat
dans le cadre des travaux préparatoires
à l'examen des projets de loi ordinaires
et organique que nous examinons
aujourd'hui je tiens à dire que le
gouvernement a refusé d'être auditionné
par les commissions saisies sur ce texte
qu'il s'agisse de la commission au fond
et de la commission pour avis et nous le
regrettons très vivement effectivement
depuis un peu plus de 4 semaines il n'y
a pas de ministrees chargé de l'énergie
en fonction ou à tout le moins j'ai pu
le lire dans la presse peut-être
Monsieur Bruno maire puisqu'il est allé
hier visiter une centrale nucléaire et
qu'il a dit qu'il était le ministre
chargé de l'énergie mais c'est vous
monsieur Béchu qui êtes cet après-midi
au banc pour autant cette situation est
véritablement inadmissible car le sujet
qui dont nous allons débattre
aujourd'hui sur la sûreté nucléaire est
un sujet sérieux car ce projet de
réforme qui concerne quelques 2000
agents publics et privés est important
et qu'est-ce est-ce qu'on constate que
le gouvernement est aux abonnés absents
effectivement il tarde à donner des
contributions tand les rapporteurs le
lui ont demandé et puis je l'ai rappelé
il n'a pas voulu être auditionné alors
on peut se poser la question il y a plus
aucune chaîne de décision depuis 4
semaines qui sont les ministres et les
directions qui sont responsables sur ce
texte cette situation n'a pas permis au
rapporteurs comme au commissaire d'aller
peut-être au fond des choses et
d'apprécier les tenants et les
aboutissants de ce texte qui est
important aussi nous aurions pu déposer
une question préalable demander le
report du texte mais comme nous sommes
responsablebl et que nous voulons que ce
texte puisse effectivement avancer
puisqu'il va dans le sens d'une relance
du plan de réforme nucléaire de la de
l'énergie nucléaire qui a beaucoup trop
tergiversé par le passé et bien nous
examinerons ce texte même si nous
déplarons comment les les débats ont pu
avoir lieu et puis je rappellerai que le
premier ministre a dit qu'il voulait
travailler en commun et bien je pense
que pour travailler en commun il faut
d'abord respecter le Parlement et pour
travailler en commun il faut aussi avoir
besoin du Sénat alors mettez votre
parole en tout cas la parole du Premier
ministre en accord avec les actes c'est
ce que nous demandons merci merci madame
la Présidente acte est donné de votre
rappel au règlement
oui je peux vous donner quelques
quelques instants
courts je vous remercie de votre étude
madame la Présidente estros çaonne en
vrai votre rappel au règlement ne me
surprend pas et j'aurais même été
surpris que vous ne commenciez pas cette
séance en pointant du fait que vous
aviez éventuellement un doute sur votre
interlocuteur à défaut que le mot
énergie figure dans les intitulés de
ceux qui ont été nommés lors de la
première vague du remanement les décrets
d'atribution viennent préciser qui
s'occupe de quoi c'est d'ailleurs à ce
titre que j'ai l'honneur et le plaisir
peut-être non réciproque de me me
trouver devant vous ce soir puisque
l'énergie pour la partie production
relève de Bercy et l'énergie pour la
partie sobriété énergétique efficacité
énergétique et sûreté nucléaire relève
du ministère de la transition
écologique avec
avec la subtilité que chacun des deux
ministères est associé aux décisions qui
relèvent de l'autre je sais que vous
n'avez au moins pas de doute sur ce qui
est ma conception du respect du
Parlement et du Sénat et je n'ai pas
pris vos propos comme personnel et vous
avez trop j'ai trop de respect pour
votre indépendance pour que vous ne
jugiez pas non plus le gouvernement
uniquement seulement sur les intitulés
mais sur les actes je déplore comme vous
que le temps n'est pas rendu possible
ces auditions que les décrets
d'attribution par rapport au moment où
vous avez commencé ce travail n'est pas
permis ne m'est pas permis de pouvoir
être auditionné dans des conditions qui
vous auraiit satisfait je veux vous dire
que à défaut de pouvoir consoler votre
courou je n'y crois pas je vais au moins
m'efforcer dans toutes les heures que
j'aurai le plaisir de passer avec vous
de vous témoigner le respect profond que
j'ai au moment où commence cette séance
parce que je n'oublie pas que le texte
qu'on s'apprête à évoquer il est aussi
le résultat du travail de l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
qu'il est la suite de vote que vous avez
mis sur un texte précédent pour qu'il y
ait un texte spécifique sur ce sujet et
que ce sera l'occasion précisément
d'aller au fond des choses et vous me
permettrez juste de saluer votre esprit
de responsabilité qui a consisté à ne
pas terminer ce rappel au règlement par
un vote qui aurait conduit à décaler
l'examen euh ça témoigne effectivement
de votre volonté de pouvoir sur le fond
regarder comment contribuer à la relance
du nucléaire et à une politique qui soit
ambitieuse pour notre
pays merci monsieur le ministre et bien
dans le cadre de la discussion générale
je vais vous redonner la
parole
madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président
longjour Madame la Présidente estros
sassonne messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le rapporteur Martin et
monsieur le rapporteur chaise mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs dans cette
assemblée il y a un an était discuté le
projet de loi à l'accélération des
procédures liées à la construction de
nouvelles installations nucléaires
aujourd'hui nous sommes appelés à
débattre d'un texte qui est tout aussi
crucial pour notre politique de
transition énergétique le projet de loi
sur la réforme de la gouvernance et de
la sûreté nucléaire et de la
radioprotection la relance de notre
filière nucléaire s'inscrit dans une
longue histoire une histoire qui a connu
un essort particulier avec le lancement
du premier programme nucléaire par le
général de Gaulle puis par des étapes
qui l'ont jalonné depuis le plan Mesmer
jusqu'au discours de Belfort du
président de la
République ce programme il doit
notamment son succès historique à la
garantie d'une exploitation sûre ainsi
qu'à la mise en place progressive d'un
cadre et d'une organisation du système
français de contrôle en sûreté nucléaire
et en radioprotection un cadre qui
repose d'abord sur la responsabilité
première des exploitants nucléaires et
sur ce point l'arrêt des réacteurs
nucléaires décidé par EDF seul au pire
de la crise énergétique que nous avons
traversé l'an dernier pour faire face au
problèmes de corrosion sous contrainte
témoigne du sérieux des milliers de
femmes et d'hommes qui exploitent ces
cathédral
technologique mais cela repose surtout
sur l'existence d'une organisation
permettant un contrôle indépendant et
reposant sur les meilleures compétces
poss possiblebl suivant les
recommandations du rapport du député
jean-v ledeo en
1998 le processus d'amélioration et de
réorganisation des services de l'État
s'est enclenché il y a plus de 20 ans un
établissement public sous tutelle
gouvernementale résultant de la fusion
de plusieurs agences et services de
l'État l'Institut de radioprection et de
sûreté nucléaire a ainsi été créé en
2002 avec déjà à l'époque les
difficultés inhérantes à toute réforme
organisationnelle puis en 2006 la loi
transparence et sécurité nucléaire a
permis le passage d'une direction
d'administration centrale à une autorité
administrative indépendante indépendante
non seulement des exploitants mais
également du gouvernement c'était la
création de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire chargée du contrôle de la
sûreté nucléaire et de la
radioprotection près de 17 ans après la
conclusion collective que nous pouvons
en tirer sur la dernière décennie et que
cette organisation a été au
rendez-vous cependant le contexte a
radicalement
changé
contrairement à la dynamique de projet
constaté ces dernières années nous
sommes en train de relancer activement
notre filière nucléaire et nous le
faisons pour baisser nos émissions pour
tenir nos engagements de sortie des
énergies fossiles pour participer à la
réindustrialisation de notre pays et
plus largement pour faire en sorte de
défendre une souveraineté énergétique
dont nous avons besoin je ne vais pas
rentrer dans l'énumération de tous les
projet associés à cette
relance qui vont accroître
significativement et dur
le volum et la complexité des dossiers
de sûreté et de radiprotection mais
permettez-moi d'en lister axes
principaux d'abord la poursuite de
l'exploitation de 56 réacteurs
nucléaires aussi longtemps que la sûreté
le
permettra ensuite la relance de la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs PR2
d'ors et déjà à P à Graveline et au
budget ensite la relance de grands
programmes de recherche et développement
développement de nouveaux réacteurs
innovants et modulaires relance d'un
programme d'investissement dans les
infrastructures du
CEA et puis la consolidation à la fois
de l'amont et de l'aval du cycle de
combustible pour mener ces chantiers le
Gouvernement s'attache à mettre tous les
maillons du nucléaire civil à leur
meilleur niveau administration publique
nationalisation de DF mise en œuvre d'un
plan Marchal des compétences
sécurisation accélération des procédure
administrative le gouvernement a ainsi
engagé une réflexion visant à faire
évoluer l'organisation de la sûreté
nucléaire pour qu'el continue de
répondre au mieux à la mission d'assurer
un contrôle indépendant et efficace du
nucléaire civil en France en mobilisant
comme en 2006 la comparaison des
meilleurs modèles internationaux
j'insiste sur le fait que ce projet de
loi ne modifie pas d'une virgule le
cadre de sûreté et de radio prototection
français applicable aux
exploitants concrètement il s'agit de
réduire les complexité d'interface qui
sont inhérents à l'exercice de ces deux
entités pour trois raisons l'ASN et
l'IRSN ont des priorités qui sont
distinctes ce qui peut limiter
l'efficacité du pilotage du bon emploi
de leur moyens et nécessite des dizaines
de documents cadres négociés pour
organiser leur relation au quotidien ils
ont des processus et des outils internes
distincts ce qui limite le partage
d'information et l'efficience des
instructions et de la gestion de crise
dans le contexte de relance du nucléaire
l'ASN et l'IRSN pourrait disputer des
compétences rares similaires limitant
les synergies qu'une mise en commun
offre dans un contexte de tension sur
ces mêmes compétences cette réflexion
elle s'était déjà posée lors de l'examen
du dernier texte sur le nucléaire au
Parlement je veux le dire d'emblé cette
méthode faisant intervenir la
proposition de réforme au milieu de la
navette parlementaire n'était pas adapté
à
l'enjeu nous en avons tiré les
conséquences avec
humilité ce projet de loi il reprend
toutes les recommandations du rapport
transpartisan de l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques du 11 juillet 2023 et je
rappelle que ce rapport a été commandé
par la présidente Sophie prima et je
tiens à saluer le sénateur Piednoir pour
le travail
méticuleux mené au côté du député
fugit le projet de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui a fait l'objet
d'un mois et demi de consultation près
de 9 instances différentes de dizaines
de réunions de travail avec les corps
sociaux de laasn et de l'IRSN d'un
examen minutieux par le Conseil d'État
pour en conforter la solidité juridique
et établir une étude d'impact de 200
pages complément je veux saluer le
travail rigoureux approfondi mené par
Pascal Martin pour la commission du
développement durable et par Patrick
chez pour la commission des affaires
économiques avant pendant l'examen du
texte en commission et je tiens à l'
remercier pour leur travail ainsi que
les présidents de ces deux commissions
que j'ai déjà salué le projet que nous
examinons aujourd'hui il repose sur la
mise en place d'une autorité
administrative indépendante qui ne sera
ni
laasn ni l'IRSN mais une nouvelle
autorité de sûreté nucléaire et de
radioprotection
elle réunira à compter du 1er janvier
2025 les compétences et les missions des
actuelles ASN et IRSN avec un calendrier
ambitieux mais qui est réaliste et
nécessaire je vous partage les principes
d'organisation de cette future autorité
prévu dans la loi premier principe
l'indépendance indépendance de l'entité
chargée du contrôle de la sûreté
nucléaire civile et de la
radioprotection vis-à-vis du
gouvernement vis-à-vis des exploitants
cette indépendance sera garanti grâce à
son statut d'autorité administrative
indépendante qui est rappelons-le le
plus protecteur existant en droit
français deè principe préserver et
renforcer les quatre piliers qui font la
force de not système de
sûreté exactement comme aujourd'hui des
compétences d'état de très haut niveau
exactement comme aujourd'hui un collège
de cinq commissaires pour prendre les
décisions et les avis les plus
importants tout en rendant compte au
Parlement et des services dont la
direction relèvera exactement comme
aujourd'hui d'un directeur
général des groupes permanents d'experts
exactement comme aujourd'hui pour
éclairer de manière indépendante les
décision de laasnr et permettre de
conforter les points de vue enfin
exactement comme aujourd'hui un
processus de consultation du public pour
les enjeux importants avant la décision
j'insiste sur le fait qu'aucune autre
autorité administrative indépendante y
compris l'actuel
ASN
n'est et ne serait autant cadré par la
loi que la future
asnr je comprends le souhait de donner
plus de visibilité sur la future
organisation et les rapporteurs ont je
le pense sur ce point apporté des gages
tangibles d'organisations qui sont
compatibles avec un objectif que je
salue à l'inverse certaines des
évolutions proposées si elles été
maintenu en l'état pourrait conduire à
des complexifications ou à des formes de
paralysie qui m'amèneront à porter des
amendements du Gouvernement pour
apporter plus de stabilité ou de
sécurité juridique au dispositifs de
manière générale je pense de sur crois
qu'il est important de ne pas brider
autre mesure le travail de préfiguration
actuellement mené par les directions
général
de l'ASN et de l'IRSN depuis fin
septembre d'autant qu'un accord de
concertation a été signé le 14 décembre
dernier entre les deux entités et leurs
organisations syndicales qu'il me semble
qu'il faut laisser à ces deux structures
des marges de
discussion 3è principe le maintien d'un
haut niveau de transparence et
d'information mise à disposition du
public garantie par la future autorité
et qui sera même renforcé par rapport à
ce qui existe aujourd'hui les
rapporteurs ont renforcé ce point par
rapport au texte initial tout en
respectant la cohérence liée à une
entité unique de même les commissions
ont proposé le renforcement des
fonctions de déontologie en prévoyant
même une commission dédiée j'y suis
favorable même si je vous proposerai un
amendement afin d'inscrire son
fonctionnement dans le cadre plus large
de la déontologie des autorités
administratives indépendantes enfin 4e
et dernier principe cette réforme veut
renforcer les compétences de la future
autorité et son
attractivité le maintien d'une capacité
de recherche dynamique le maintien d'une
capacité de recherche reconnue au niveau
mondial le maintien d'une capacité de
recherche avec des partenariats
diversifié en France et à
l'international est absolument essentiel
c'est pourquoi les activités de
recherche actuellement conduites par
l'IRSN se poursuivront au sein de la
future autorité le projet de loi apporte
des réponses concrètes et inédites aux
enjeux de tension sur les compétences
dans les filières constaté depuis
plusieurs années en apportant des
réponses
clairesugment ation de
rémunération opportunité de parcours de
carrière plus large ou encore meilleure
allocation des compétences rare de
l'État enfin ce projet contribue
également à la relance nucléaire en
permettant au matres d'ouvrage en
particulier F de passer leur marché
selon des modalités qui sont plus adapté
à leur contraintte industriell et de
renforcer la protection des intérêts
essentiels de la nation afin de tenir
compte du contexte international
mesdames et messieurs ce texte témoigne
de nouveau de la détermination du
gouvernement de se donner ement les
moyens de réussir la relance de la
filière nucléaire en toute sûreté une
relance dont l'opportunité climatique se
renforce chaque jour et une relance dont
l'opportunité est désormais très
largement partagée par une majorité de
Français ce texte témoigne aussi de la
vigilance du Parlement et de votre
assemblée en particulier sur le souhait
d'accompagner cette relance en faisant
en sorte qu'elle se déroule avec les
meilleurs standards je souhaite que
notre travail permett de faire encore
progresser un texte qui nous permettra
de maintenir dans la durée l'excellence
de de la sûreté nucléaire et de la radio
protection française auquel le
gouvernement comme tous les Français
sont très
attachés merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Pascal Martin
rapporteur de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable pour 10
minutes madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente Estrosi
Sasson monsieur le Président longjot
Monsieur le Président de l'opexte
Piednoir monsieur le rapporteur chaise
mes chers collègues nous sommes réunis
ce soir pour l'examen du projet de loi
relatif à l'organisation de la
gouvernance de la sûreté nucléaire et de
la radioprotection pour répondre au défi
de la relance de la filière nucléaire et
du projet de loi organique associé j'ai
organisé durant les premières semaines
de janvier une vingtaine d'auditions
j'ai également souhaité travailler en
bonne intelligence avec la commission
des Affaires chcho saisie pour avis et
au fond sur quatre articles certains
certaines de ces auditions ont ainsi été
organisé conjointement avec Patrick
chaise dans un très bon climat il y a
près d'un an vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur monsieur le ministre dans le
cadre de l'examen du projet de loi
accélération du nucléaire à l'Assemblée
nationale le gouvernement avait proposé
la fusion entre l'ASN autorité
administrativ indépendantes en charge de
prendre les décisions individuelles et
réglementaires et IRSN établissement
public exerçant des mission d'expertise
et de recherche dans le domaine de la
sûreté de la sécurité des installations
et de la
radiioprotection nous avions été très
nombreux au Sénat à déplorer la méthode
employé cette proposition n'avait fait
l'objet d'aucune concertation ni
d'aucune évaluation et n'avait pas été
soumise à la première assemblée saisie
le Sénat la proposition de gouvernement
avait finalement été rejetée par les
députés malmené le Parlement a réagi par
le biais d'une saisine de
l'opexte ce rapport son rapport de
l'OPEX de Stéphane Piednoir et Jean-Luc
fugi paru en juillet dernier dont je
salue la qualité alimenté le projet de
fusion proposé par le gouvernement et a
largement inspiré les amendements
adoptés par la commission pour l'examen
de ces textes la mission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable c'est fixé une
priorité
essentielle maintenir notre sûreté
nucléaire au niveau d'exigence le plus
élevé possible en l'adaptant aux enjeux
de notre décennie et celles à venir j'ai
ainsi effectué une instruction à charge
et à décharge en m'appuyant notamment
sur le rapport de l'OPEX et sur une
étude pardon de législation comparée
demandé au service du Sénat cette
instruction m'a conduit à identifier C
avantages à la proposer de la
gouvernance de la Sûreté
Nucléaire premier avantage une
efficacité accrue j'ai pu constater au
cours de mes auditions l'excellence du
système français de sûreté nucléaire
reconnu par l'ensemble des parties
prenantes à l'échelle nationale comme
internationale toutefois notre système
de sûreté nucléaire doit aujourd'hui
s'adapter à l'évolution du flux de
demande vous le savez la relance du
nucléaire est un chantier d'une ampleur
inédite un programme hors norme la
nouvelle organisation permettra de
mettre fin aux frictions qui ont pu
exister dans les échanges entre l'ASN et
l'IRSN aux différences de priorisation
qui génèent aujourd'hui des délais
supplémentaires dans la prise de
décision deuxième avantage une meilleure
adaptation aux enjeux contemporains de
la Sûreté Nucléaire le premier enjeu
contemporain est celui des petits
réacteurs modulaires ou SMR développés
notamment par des start-ups j'ai pu
entendre dans le cadre de mes auditions
les start-ups françaises engagé dans une
véritable course technologique contre
les autres puissances nucléaires j'ai
entendu une forte demande de
simplification et de meilleur
accompagnement par les pouvoirs publics
à laquelle la fusion contribuera à
répondre le deuxième enjeu contemporain
est le dérèglement climatique le grand
défi du siècle en matière de sûreté
nucléaire sera l'adaptation des parcs
existants et à venir à cette réalité
regrouper l'ensemble des avvoir-fair
nécessaires contribuera à armer notre
pays face à ce défi immense trème
avantage une amélioration de la gestion
de crise pour assurer leur mission en
cas de crise l'IRSN et l'ASN dispose
chacun d'un centre de crise d'une
organisation spécifique et de moyens
propres en la matière la fusion
permettra au services de l'État de
disposer d'un interlocuteur unique et
fludifiera les échanges entre les
différentes équipes 4ème avantage une
clarification de la communication
combien de nos concitoyens aujourd'hui
sont capables de distinguer les missions
de l'ASN de celle de l'IRSN émanant de
deux institutions différentes la
communication a pu donner lieu par le
passé à des cafouillages
préjudiciable la réforme permettra à la
nouvelle autorité de parler d'une voix
commune et partant facilitera
l'identification par le public de
l'autorité décisionnaire enfin 5è
avantage un renforcement de
l'attractivité vous le savez il manquera
pour la décennie à venir 100000 emplois
dans la filière nucléaire donc
possibilité d'être recruter sous
différents statuts d'en changer
renforcement des opportunités de
mobilité professionnelle les paramètres
retenus par le gouvernement
constitueront des opportunités pour
rendre la future autorité plus
attractive une part de la réaction face
au déficit d'attractivité des instances
de sûreté réside néanmoins dans
l'augmentation des rémunérations et des
moyens hum humains pardon un sujet à
inscrire dans la durée que le
gouvernement n'a pas ce jour voulu
prendre suffisamment au sérieux en dépit
des nombreuses alertes
parlementaire vous l'aurez compris la
réforme de la gouvernance de la Sûreté
Nucléaire permettra de renforcer le
système de sûreté français dans un
contexte hor norme le projet qui nous a
été soumis présentait cependant des
risques qui ont conduit la Commission à
ajuster le texte présenté par le
gouvernement premier risque auquel nous
avons souhaité répondre la distinction
entre expertise et décision ce sujet est
crucial primordial car la distinction
expertise décision est au cœur de la
qualité de la crédibilité du système de
sûreté d'une part puisque
différenciation insuffisante risque de
placer l'expertise sous l'influence de
la décision les conclusions de
l'expertise seraient orientées dans le
sens de la décision ou inversement la
décision sansé tenir compte de
l'expertise mais également d'enjeux
comme l'approvisionnement en électricité
du pays pourrait ne pas s'autonomiser
suffisamment des avis scientifiques qui
lui sont présentés d'autre part car
démontrer la sûreté c'est confronter le
doute ce n'est pas l'affirmation de
certitude qui rassure le public sur
l'état de la sûreté nucléaire mais la
transparence sur les débats internes au
système à ce sujet le projet de loi
constitué dans sa rédaction initiale un
recul d'abord sur la méthode en
renvoyant le sujet au règlement
intérieur de la future autorité et
surtout sur le fond en prévoyant une
distinction des processus d'expertise et
de décision uniquement dans le cas d'une
prise de décision par le collège soit 30
dossiers par an contre 300 dossiers
aujourd'hui un redémarrage de centrale
nucléaire n'aurait ainsi plus fait
l'objet d'une expertise distincte du
reste de l'instruction la Commission a
préféré adopter une position d'équilibre
qui préserverait la fluidité permise par
la fusion des deux entités tout en
garantissant la confrontation des doutes
indispensables à la sûreté premier
avantage du texte adopté en commission
il étend le champ de la distinction à
l'ensemble des dossiers à enjeu et pas
seulement aux 30 sujets annuels
nécessitant une décision du Collège
deuxième avantage nous proposons une
distinction des responsabilités plutôt
que des processus notion
particulièrement flou du texte initial
il serait ainsi assuré que le signataire
de l'expertise n'est pas le même que le
signataire de la décision mais la
distinction des responsabilités et donc
des signataires ne suffit pas notre
objectif est de consacrer une
distinction expertise décision qui ne
soit soit pas que de papier il nous a
semblé que ce principe devait se
traduire concrètement dans
l'organisation des instructions c'est
pourquoi nous avons souhaité préciser
que le règlement intérieur fixera les
modalités organisationnelles de
distinction et d'interaction des
personnels en charge de l'expertise et
de la décision cette précision garantira
sur un dossier donné que les personnels
en charge de l'expertise d'une part et
ceux en charge de la décision d'autre
part seront bien identifiés notre idée
n'est pas ici de recréer au sein de la
future asnr un pôle expertise distinct
d'un pôle décision cela reviendrait à
rejouer au sein de l'asnr le face- à
faceace ASN IRSN on perdrait alors tous
les bénéfices de la réforme le texte de
commission renforce également
l'expertise tierce en donnant une assise
juridique forte aux groupes permanents
d'experts les GPE comme le proposé le
rapport de l'opexte ces groupes
constitués de spécialistes contribue au
processus d'expertise en apportant un
regard critique et des compétences
spécialisées deuxième problème du texte
initial le risque d'un recul en matière
de transparence la la crédibilité de
notre système de sûreté nucléaire repose
pourtant sur cette exigence qui apparaît
indispensable pour assurer
l'acceptabilité de la relance de l'atome
dans notre pays par la population en
renvoyant au règlement intérieur les
modalités de publication des résultats
des activités d'expertise de la nouvelle
asnr le projet de loi initiale
comportait des risques de recul en la
matière puisqu'il n'était pas certain
que l'exigence de publication soit
conservée et encore moins qu'elle soit
renforcée c'est pourquoi la Commission a
adopté un amendement intégrant la loi
comme le proposé le rapport de lopex le
principe de publication des résultats
d'expertise pour maintenir un niveau de
transparence équivalent à celui atteint
par le système actuel 3ième problème que
nous avons identifié le maintien des
activités de recherche le projet de loi
initiale comportait des risques pour la
conduite des activités de recherche de
la future asnr activités qui sont le
socle de l'expertise en matière de
sûreté de radioprotection les acquis de
l'IRSN sa notoriété et sa visibilité
dans le monde de la recherche devront
être préservés comme l'a souligné le
rapport de l'opexte en particulier la
SNR devra poursuivre la collaboration
engagée par l'IRSN avec les industriels
du secteur nucléaire indispensable à la
recherche en sûreté nucléaire enfin le
4e risque du texte initial était relatif
à l'association du Parlement et de
société civile de nombreux sujetsur
majeurs seront renvoyés au règlement
intérieur de la future autorité ce choix
est justifié par la nécessité d'assurer
une plus grande souplesse dans le
fonctionnement de l'autorité une
rédition des comptes sera cependant
nécessaire c'est pourquoi la Commission
adopté j'y viens madame la Présidente
sur la proposition notamment du
rapporteur pour avis chaise des
amendements qui renforcent l'association
à ce règlement intérieur de l'OPEX du
Haut comité et de l'ANCLI et des
commissions permanentes compétentes des
deux assemblées en définitive le projet
projet de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui est un texte rééquilibré qui
adapte la Sûreté Nucléaire aux enjeux de
notre décennie tout en maintenant la
sûreté nucléaire au niveau d'exigence
mais aussi de transparence le plus élevé
possible je merci merci merci monsieur
le rapporteur la parole est à notre
collègue Patrick Chise rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des affaires
économiques pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame et monsieurs les
présidents de commission mon cher
collègue rapporteur monsieur le
Président de l'OPEX mes chers collègues
les projets de loi ordinaire et
organique que nous examinons aujourd'hui
propose trois réformes techniques
destinées à accompagner la relance de la
filière française du nucléaire acté par
la loi nouveau nucléaire du 22 juin 2023
la commission des affaires économiques
est en charge de l'examen au fond des
article 12 et 16 à 18 du projet de loi
ordinaire c'est-à-dire ceux sur la
simplification des règles de la commande
publique et le repositionnement du Haut
Commissaire à l'énergie atomique elle
s'est saisie pour avis des autres
article du projet de loi qui porte sur
la création de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire et de radio prototection
l'asnr lors de l'examen de la loi
nouveau nucléaire le gouvernement avait
déposé à l'Assemblée nationale deux
amendements procédant à la fusion de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire et de
l'Institut de radio protection et de
sûreté nucléaire en commission mixte
paritaire notre rapporteur que je salue
Daniel grimier avait expurgé le texte de
toute référence à la fusion de plus
notre présidente avait saisi l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques en
rejetant les amendements présentés à la
hatâte par le gouvernement et vous
l'avez reconnu monsieur le ministre
après le vote massif du Sénat sur ce
texte notre commission s'était opposée à
une réforme mal anticipée et mal évaluée
en saisissant l'OPEX elle avait remis
les parlementaires au cœur des enjeux le
nouveau projet de réforme est plus
abouti mais nous pouvons néanmoins
regretter le fait que nous n'ayons pas
pu auditionner le ministre en charge de
ce dossier plus abouti disais-je car il
est le fruit de rapport de l'opexte
d'une dizaine de consultations et d'un
an de concertation il arrive au moment
crucial de la relance du nucléaire le
gouvernement devant proposer de
nouvelles régulations et programmation
énergétique dans le projet de loi
souveraineté énergétique et la
programmation pluannuelle de l'énergie
notre Commission soutient aujourd'hui
dans son principe le nouveau projet de
réforme plus abouti que le précédent
parce qu'il vise à fluidifier les
procédures d'instruction à sûreté
inchangé il est indispensable à la
relance du nucléaire à l'heure où les
dossiers vont se multiplier renforcer
l'efficacité du système n'a rien de
superflu certes les modalités du projet
posent des défis en terme de continuité
des procédures de valorisation des
compétences et de maintien des standards
pour autant à terme le projet de nature
à renforcer la confiance du public car
la nouvelle autorité serait une autorité
administrative
indépendante dans le cadre de mes
travaux préparatoires j'ai entendu une
quarantaine de personnalités lors d'une
vingtaine d'auditions au total j'ai
proposé à notre commission 37
amendements selon quatre axes consolider
la gouvernance de la filière du
nucléaire simplifier les règles de la
commande publicque faire suite aux
travaux de la loi nouveau nucléaire et
conforter l'organisation de l'autorité
de S
25 de ces amendements ont été adoptés en
commission j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir sur les autres qui seront
réexaminer le premier axe de mes travaux
vise à consolider la gouvernance de la
filière du nucléaire en renforçant les
attributions et le fonctionnement du
Haut Commissaire à l'énergie atomique et
en prévoyant que le Parlement puisse le
saisir pour avis et se prononcer sur sa
désignation 79 ans après sa création par
le général de Gaulle j'entends faire du
Haut Commissaire la vigie de la relance
du
nucléaire le deuxème axe tend à
simplifier les règles de la commande
publique des projet nucléaire en
confortant les dérogations prévues en
matière d'allotissement de durée des
accords cadres et de règles de publicité
et de concurrence et en ajoutant un
critère de crédibilité et une
possibilité d'avenant ces soupless sont
nécessaires pour prévenir tout risque
d'interface de rupture et Infiné de
surcout je rappelle qu'un retard d'un
mois sur un réacteur peut engendrer 100
millions d'euros selon
EDF un autre axe est de faire suite à la
loi nouveau nucléaire en proposant
d'appliquer les recommandations du
rapport de l'OPEX et de réintroduire des
dispositions visant à appliquer une
règle de parité dans le collège de
l'autorité et une règle de publicité
dans sa commission des sanctions c'est
un gage de
cohérence le dernier axe propose de
conforter l'organisation de l'Autorité
de sûreté notamment en matière de
garantie d'indépendance et de
déontologie de séparation entre le
processus d'expertise et de contrôle de
publication des rapports et des
décisions ou d'association de l'OPEX et
des commissions
permanentes je souhaite aussi consacrer
l'indépendance de l'autorité et
sanctuariser ses activités régaliennes
je veux à ce stade remercier le
rapporteur Pascal Martin pour nos
échanges constructifs au nom de notre
commission je vous invite à adopter les
projets de loi sous réserve bien sûr des
adoptions de mes amendements je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
pour avis la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane piernoir président de l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques pour 5
minutes madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
madame la Présidente présidente de
commission chers collègues l'opeex né du
du constat unanime à l'époque selon
lequel la France s'est engagée dans le
nucléaire sans qu'à aucun moment le
Parlement se soit prononcer sur les
choix scientifiques lourds et de long
terme que cela impliquait depuis sa
création il y a 40 ans donc l'OPEX que
j'ai l'honneur de présider s'intéresse
de près au sujet majeur de la sûreté
nucléaire dans notre pays il y a
consacré une vingtaine de rapports
notamment celui rédigé par le sénateur
et ancien président de l'office Jean
Jean-Marie roche qui nous a quitté il y
a quelques jours et dont je salue la
mémoire tirant les conséquences de
l'accident de de tchernoby ce rapport
AAC comme principale recommandation la
création d'une Agence nationale de la
sécurité et de l'information nucléaire
indépendante des pouvoirs publics et des
exploitants d'installation nucléaire
autrement dit la future
ASN il était clair alors pour l'office
que les structures de contrôle internes
au CEA et au ministère de l'Industrie
n'étaient plus adaptées pour assurer un
contrôle véritablement indépendant de
notre sûreté nucléaire l'analyse des
systèmes étrangers loin d'être tous
identiques avait également convaincu
notre nos prédécesseurs il a néanmoins
fallu attendre près de 20 longues années
avant que cette nouvelle organisation se
mette en place ce qui n'a pas été sans
remou ni polémique à l'époque la
nouvelle étape proposé aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement me conduit à faire trois
séries
d'observations la première sera
évidemment sur la forme pour me
féliciter que cette réforme se fasse à
travers un projet de loi spécifique
après la maladroite tentative de l'an
dernier par amendement gouvernemental de
dernière minute la sûreté de nos
installations nucléaaires est un
impératif absolu sur lequel le Parlement
doit pouvoir prendre le temps de
débattre dès le printemps dernier donc
l'OPEX a organisé une audition publique
réunissant toutes les parties prenantes
pour faire un point sur les enjeux et
les éventuelles conséquences de la
réforme puis sur cesine de la commission
des affaires économiques du Sénat
présidée par Sophie prima à l'époque
avec mon collègue député Jean-Luc fugit
nous avons mené de nombreuses auditions
pour évaluer en profondeur les impacts
d'une réorganisation de l'ASN et de
l'IRSN notre rapport adopté par l'Office
en juillet dernier contenait 17
recommandations qui qui ont inspiré au
moins en partie le travail des deux
commissions du Sénat sur le projet de
loi ma deuxième série d'observations
concerne le contexte de la réforme nous
ne pouvons plus raisonner aujourd'hui
comme nous le faisions au début des
années 2000 période de grand calme dans
le domaine nucléaire la relance du
nucléaire avec la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs l'arrivée de petits
réacteurs innovants l'adaptation au
changement climatique la prise en compte
de la menace cyber sans oublier le suivi
du parc actuel ou ou encore le
démantellement d'installation anciennes
tout cela nécessite une organisation du
contrôle de sûreté renforcé et robuste
il est important de s'en préoccuper sans
perdre de temps et d'anticiper la charge
des années à venir cette nouvelle donne
inédite par son ampleur doit être prise
en compte et représentera un immense
défi pour la nouvelle
asnr ma troème série d'observations
concerne le contenu et les modalités de
la réforme la sûreté nucléaire est
d'abord et avant tout la responsabilité
des exploitants faut-il le rappeler et
c'est bien EDF par exemple qui a détecté
le problème de corrosion sous contrainte
dans un certain nombre de ces réacteurs
avant d'engager un dialogue technique
avec l'IRSN et l'ASN la sûreté nucléaire
c'est une fabrication quotidienne faite
de discussion entre l'exploitant les
experts et l'Autorité de
sûreté de même l'expertise est multiple
elle existe chez l'exploitant au sein de
l'IRSN bien bien sûr mais également à
l'ASN et aussi au sein des groupes
permanents d'experts qui ont un rôle clé
pour certains sujets particulièrement
sensible dans la continuité la nouvelle
asnr devra veiller à bien respecter ces
principes et à distinguer l'expertise
qui doit rester indépendante de la
décision sans toutefois la conditionner
de manière
automatique l'Office tient à ce qu'un
haut niveau d'information se
maintiennent et même se renforce en
utilisant tous les canaux de diffusion
possiblees
car si l'acceptabilité du nucléaire
passe par un niveau de sûreté élevé elle
dépend aussi d'une très grande
transparence l'Office a pleine confiance
dans les acteurs actuels de la Sûreté
Nucléaire et dans leur capacité à
réussir la réforme aujourd'hui proposée
monsieur le ministre cette
responsabilité vous incombe aujourd'hui
tout comme la relance du nucléaire dans
notre pays jusqu'à futur nomination en
tout cas au service des commissions
l'OPEX se réjouit et très heureux
d'avoir été associé à ce débat si
important et exercera un contrôle
attentif sur les différents aspects de
la mise en place de la nouvelle autorité
et en particulier veillera à ce que le
renforcement des moyens humains et
financiers pour le contrôle l'expertise
et la recherche soit bien assuré par le
gouvernement je vous remercie merci
monsieur le
Président nous passons à la discussion
de la motion tendant à opposer la
question préalable monsieur renandantec
et les membres du groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire ont déposé une
motion distribué sous le numéro 1
tendant à opposer la question préalable
au projet de loi donc la parole est à
Monsieur ronand Dantec pour la motion
pour 10 minutes
maximum madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le Président chers collègues en
un peu plus de 12 ans de présence au
Sénat je défends ici pour la première
fois une question préalable je n'en suis
pas accoutumier tant je considère et je
sais que nous sommes nombreux sur ces
bans à partager cette conviction que
notre mission est de légiférer de
discuter et d'améliorer les textes de
loi pas de refuser le débat une question
préalable n'est justifiable que si elle
répond à plusieurs difficultés la
première bien sûr c'est l'importance du
sujet sommes-nous ici sur un enjeu
majeur pour la sécurité nationale la
réponse est bien évidemment oui quand on
est encore le 2e pays le plus équipé au
monde en centrale nucléaire qui plus est
avec des centrales vieillissantes ou
pour la dernière la dernière en rodage
de très très longue durée sûreté et
sécurité nucléaire ne sont pas des
petits sujets mais des questions
essentielles pour l'avenir du pays la
seconde difficulté tient évidemment au
temps et au moyens réservés au débat
parlementairirees avons-nous eu ce temps
la réponse est évidemment non j'ai même
le sentiment qu'il y a consensus sur ce
point nous sommes heureux de vous
retrouver au banc monsieur le ministre
mais nous n'avons même pas eu l'occasion
de vous auditionner en commission certes
il y avait des contrainte de
remanimement nous l'avons bien compris
mais il convenait dans ce cas de
repousser ce projet de loi le temps
politique légitime d'une constitution
d'un casting gouvernemental ne pouvait
en aucune manière passer avant la
sécurité collective des Français la
question préalable est donc plus que
justifiée j'invite à son adoption notre
accord semblait assez total avec la
présidence estrosis Sasson mais je ne
vois pas où est le mot responsabilité
est-ce responsable d'accélérer après
avoir fait le constat qu'il n'y avait
pas eu débat il y a là une contradiction
sur lesquelle il nous faudra
revenir si encore en lisant les attendus
du projet de loi ou à travers l'audition
conjointe de l'ASN et l'IRSN nous avions
pu comprendre la totalité des raisons de
ce bouleversement en profondeur du
système de la sûreté de la sécurité nous
nous étions jusqu'à peu si fiers y
compris sur les bancs de la majorité
sénatoriale beaucoup de questions donc
sans réponse certes un mot magique s'est
imposé
fluidité c'est fou à quel point dès
qu'il s'agit du nucléaire il nous faut
des mots magiques abracadabra et d'un
coup de baguette magique l'état fait
disparaître l'IRSN
entre parenthèses je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs si c'est avec la même formule
qu'il a aussi fait disparaître entre
temp la faite qui tenait la baguette
fluidité le système est donc un peu
grippé et au moment où l'État appuie sur
l'accélérateur je n'ai pas dit sur le
champignon parce qu'avec nucléaire ça
serait assez malencontreux donc l'état
appuie sur l'accélérateur et Bing
l'embrayage de la sûreté saute et bloque
des vitesses vite de l'huile de l'huile
et du carburant parce qu'au moins
l'audition du président de la SN aura
été édifiante sur un point trop de
sollicitations trop d'avis à rendre
entre central haristelet et comme ça a
été dit cher Christophe Béchu avec en
plus plus 4 degrés d'augmentation des
températures pr toujours en rodage
démentantellement stockage des déchets
multiplication des projets de petits
réacteurs modulair aux technologies
aussi complexes que différent suvant les
producteurs il n'y a pas les moyens que
laasn joue son rôle vous voulez un
exemple de cette pression à l'œuvre le
rapport de 2023 de l'opexte est clair à
ce sujet je le le projet newward c'est
un SMR n'étant pas aussi avancé que les
principaux projets étrangers concurrents
les équipes de l'ASN et l'ursn seront
probablement soumises à une très forte
pression pour assurer l'instruction des
dossiers dans des délais aussi courts
que poss possible tout est dit on aura
donc compris que laasn a besoin de monde
pour assurer ses propres missions et
l'ordre sur le personnel de l'IRSN bien
plus conséquent et au passage on rêve
mais ça ne nous a pas été vraiment
démontré par l'exemple que que certains
processus iront beaucoup plus rapidement
une structure centralisée et pyramidale
agissant plus vite que deux structures
devant ce coordonné certes mais si on a
un esprit un peu simple on en conclut
aussi que cela signifie plus de
ressources humaines pour alimenter
directement les décisions de l'asnr et
donc moins de recherche autonome en
capacité de s'intéresser à des questions
que personne ne lui a posé c'est un des
risques majeurs de ce projet de fusion
ayant quelques minutes je me permets de
vous lire ces extraits de la tribune
dans Le Monde de Philippe lorino
ingénieur des mines membres du groupe
permanent d'experts réacteurs auprès de
l'autorité de scurité nucléaire je cite
les analyses réalisées par le sociologue
spécialisé en analyse de risque Charles
Perraud sur l'accident nucléire de smal
Island aux États-Unis en 79 et sur
d'autres accidents dans les secteurs
aéronautiques pétrochimiques et
maritimes conclut au fait que la
multiplicité et la variété des points de
vue permettent d'assurer un scepticisme
organisé le contraire d'une confiance
aveugle et améliore significativement le
niveau de sûreté en évitant le
monolitisme de l'organisation il est
probable qu'une fusion de l'IRSN avec
laasm contribue je le cite toujours à
une plus grande homogénéité de point de
vue la fusion fera perdre en diversité
et donc en triangulation de l'analyse de
risque cette question de triangulation
est central les États-Unis souvent cités
ont certes une structure unique mais
aussi des laboratoir hisire de recherche
indépendant dans les grandes universités
qui joue ce joue ce rôle de recul voire
de poil à gratter une question simple
monsieur le ministre prévoyez-vous
d'allouer des budgets spécifiques à des
universités françaises pour qu'ell
puisse en toute autonomie se poser des
questions relative à la sûreté et à la
sécurité nucléaire voilà une question
intéressante parmi d'autres dont nous
n'avons pu débattre nous partageons avec
Pascal Martin dont je salue le travail
en urgence une certaine culture du
risque je fis longtemps aussi
vice-président n de Métropole en charge
du risque nous connaissons ces exercices
où nous imaginons l'inimaginable avec
des chercheurs en sens social avec de
simples citoyens et ces moments sont
essentiels ils amènent des questions que
nous ne nous étions pas posé nous
pouvons donc craindre la fin ou au moins
l'affaiblissement de ces regards
extérieurs de cette triangulation qui
est le socle de la sécurité et de la
sûreté à minima il s'agit au moins de
fermement séparé au sein de la nouvelle
structure Pascal Martin l'a dit
l'expertise technique du circuit de la
décision ce point nous semblait même à
peu près acté et les amendements des
rapporteurs que nous avons d'ailleurs
soutenus allai en ce sens certains des
amendements de suppression du
gouvernement sont sur ce point
extrêmement inquiétant confirme notre
inquiétude sur les raisons de cette
fusion accélérer accélérer quitte à
réduire la sécurité ne pas avoir eu le
temps de vraiment discuter avec l'État
et entre nous justifie encore une fois
la question prélable j'espère aussi que
le débat dans cet hémicycle sera
l'occasion pour la droite sénatoriale de
s'engager fermement à ne jamais accepter
une CMP qui ne garantirait pas une
stricte séparation entre expertise et
processus de décision et de réduire
aussi évidemment le relôaisser un
règlement intérieur certes lui aussi un
peu magique que nul ne pourra lire avant
son adoption beaucoup d'autres sujets
auraient nécessité des
approfondissements que deviendra par
exemple l'action menée par l'IRSN de
formation des acteurs des commissions
locales d'information ce rôle éviter que
les CLIS se perde dans de fausses
questions permettait d'objectiver le
débat et de renforcer la confiance il
aurait aussi été opportun d'entendre
leur association nationale et de
recueillir son avis je note d'ailleurs
que certains acteurs très mal
intentionnés clairement disons-le Jose
le mot antinucléaire nous disattendre
avec une certaine gourmandise cette
fusion car ils estiment qu'au dieieux
d'accélérer le retour du nucléaire ça
sera un des éléments des futurs blocages
je n'ai pas le temps même en 10 minutes
d'énumérer tous les avis qui soulligne
que cette réforme est précipitée y
compris des acteurs pas franchement IPI
je reprends IPI parce que comme c'est
ressorti ce matin au commission je
trouve ça un côté 70 qui correspond
assez bien à l'époque que l'OPEX
souligne je cite que la transition vers
une nouvelle organisation pourraêtre
source de difficulté que la plupart des
organismes consultés HN CNDA sp enc CNTE
et i de for réser aurait dû suffire pour
que ne nous précipitions pas mais les
chevaliers du nucléaire n'ont jamais
douté de leur autorité ont toujours
considéré que nul ne pouvait se dresser
sur le route qu'ils étaient le progrès
et que les manant n'avaient pas leur
mots à dire comme le soulligne l'exposé
des motifs gloire aux années mesmè ce
n'était pas non plus notre plus grand
temps démocratique et sur le nucléaire
en particulier c'est un moment où on ne
demandait jamais son avis au
Parlement merci je n'ai pas été saisi de
demandes de parole contre la motion je
vais donc demander quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le
rapporteur alors madame la Présidente
j'aimerais répondre à certains arguments
développé par Renand DC dans l'objet de
cette cupé je ne vois pas en quoi le
passage d' système dual un système
unique remettrait gravement en cause
notre système de sûreté nucléaire et de
radioprotection comme cela a pu être
avancé de nombreux pays dans le monde
alors je citerai les États-Unis le
Canada dispose d'un système unique
est-ceàdire que le niveau de protection
de la population et de l'environnement y
est plus faible qu'en France il y a des
risques associés à cette réforme je ne
le l pas et je l'ai toujours dit mais je
pense que nous avons apporté des
réponses fortes par les amendements
adoptés en commission notamment en
matière de distinction entre les
l'expertise et la décision vous dites
que l'étude d'impact du projet de loi et
sont exposé des motifs ne permettent pas
d'apprécier les réels progrès
qu'apporterait la réforme je vous suis
en parti j'estime que le gouvernement a
manqué certes de pédagogie sur ce texte
mais je peux vous assurer que des
avantages il y en a je vous les ai
d'ailleurs présenté en commission et
aujourd'hui ce sera le cas en séance
publique la relance de la filière et la
prolongation de la durée de vie du parc
actuel conduisent déjà à croître la
charge de travail des instances de
sûreté il serait donc tentant de
renoncer à la réforme pour ne pas
déstabiliser le système mais la pression
continuera de s'amplifier dans les
années à venir et il sera alors trop
tard pour bénéficier des avantages
attendus de la réforme comme l'a noté le
rapport précdé de l'OPEX au regard du
calendrier de travail une fenêtre
d'opportunités s'offre au législateur
mais pourrait rapidement se refermer
s'il faut agir il faut le faire dès à
présent vous affirmez que ce qui manque
aujourd'hui ce sont les vocations les
ressources humaines et les moyens
alloués à l'expertise comm au contrôle
je vous rejoins mais d'une part
l'augmentation des rémunérations et des
moyens humains ne relève pas d'une loi
ordinaire et d'autre part j'estime que
la nouvelle organisation permettra
justement d'éviter la dispersion des
compétences techniques et scientifiques
rares ce qui ce que des mesures
budgétaires et salariales ne pourront
pas faire seules enfin je regrette
également que nous n'ayons pas pu
entendre un ministre sur ce texte nous
avons cependant passer un peu plus de 3
heures en plainère avec le président de
la SN et le directeur général de l'IRS
je pense que cette séquence nous a
permis tous ensemble de mieux comprendre
les tenants et les aboutissants de la
réforme preuve en est les échanges en
commission et les amendements déposés en
séance ce jour pour toutes ces raisons
la commission émet un avis défavorable à
cette question préalable merci monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le ministre quel
est l'avis du
Gouvernement je dois dire à renal dantc
que
je ne crois pas un seul instant que même
s'il y avait eu l'audition d'un ministre
sa position sur ce texte aurait
changé je dois dire à renalc que même si
nous avions eu 6 mois de plus pour
discuter du sujet sa position n'aurait
pas changé je lui reconnaît l'honnêteté
intellectuelle d'utiliser tous les
moyens pour faire en sorte de stopper la
relance du nucléaire à laquelle il ne
croit pas la seule raison objective de
s'opposer à ce texte c'est si on
considère qu'il ne faut pas relancer le
nucléaire et qu'il faut rester en l'état
et donc que ça doit être le statut quo
je parle bien de l'ensemble du
dispositif et donc dans ces conditions
le gouvernement est évidemment
défavorable à l'adoption de cette motion
de rejet merci Monsieur le Ministre
alors nous passons aux explications de
vote et Monsieur Montauger a souhaité
s'exprimer pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues nous partageons l'argument
centrale de cette question préalable ce
projet de création d'une autorité de
sreté nucléaire de protection est
insuffisamment fondé en raison les
objectifs le plan de charge les
principes éthiques et déontologiques de
fonctionnement des processus
scientifiques et techniques comme les
perspectives de gestion des personnels
et des carrières ne permettent pas
d'apporter les garanties nécessaires au
législateur tous les organismes et
parties prenantes amené à s'exprimer sur
la genèse de ce projet ont émis doutes
et réserves c'est le cas du CNTE et de
l'agence nationale euh des des CLIS pour
les territoires les plus directement
concernés il en est de même pour les
personnels des deux établissements donct
je salue ici les les représentants sans
ministre en charge de ce dossier
pourtant hautement stratégique le Sénat
ça a été dit n'a pas pu interroger le
gouvernement de manière assez incroyable
au plan législatif le travail de fond
des rapporteurs a été réalisé sans
interlocuteur ministériel sans connaître
non plus le futur plan de charge de
l'établissement projeté puisque que nous
restons toujours dans l'attente d'une
proposition de programmation plurénelle
de l'énergie à débattre la politique
nucléaire française devra aussi très
vite intégrer la problématique de la
sûreté et de la radioprotection dans le
cadre du mix énergétique intégrant
probablement les technologies nucléaires
nouvelles à venir et ce n'est pas rien
en définitive et c'est le point majeur
la confiance de la population française
dans la Sûreté Nucléaire nécessite un
débat approfondi avec le grand public et
la ensemble des parties prenantes et il
n'y aura pas de confiance sans
transparence à cet égard pour toutes ces
raisons de fond le groupe socialiste
écologiste républicain votera pour cette
question préalable je vous remercie mer
explication de vote monsieur grevallet
pour le groupe
RDSE non non non non pas pour le groupe
RDSE à titre
personnel et très personnel d'ailleurs
s'agissant de cette question group c'est
une explication par groupe ah pardon
mais vous pouvez vous exprimer alors je
peux m'exprimer mais il n'y aura pas
d'autre explication pour le RDS bien sr
pour dire que en tout point je suis
d'accord avec le ministre et comme je
suis contre le plan de relance nucléaire
et comme cette formule devenue célèbre
quand c'est flou c'est qu'il y a un loup
je ne je voterai cette motion
préalable merci Monsieur Fabien gu pour
le groupe
CRCE oui merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
vous avez un problème monsieur le
ministre avec ce projet de loi et je
reviens sur l'audition que nous avons eu
du du président de laasn qui nous a dit
il faut pas être contre les réformes les
réformes ça a parfois du bon je le
rejoins sur cette question là mais il
faut nous expliquer pourquoi la réforme
vous venez de vous exprimé et aussi les
rapporteurs on les a écouté
attentivement et vous nous avez expliqué
qu'on avait des super équipe du côté de
l'ASN et des super équipes du côté de
l'IRSN alors pourquoi parce que si on
fait une réforme c'est qu'il y a un
problème et que vous recherchez de
l'efficacité mais vous venez nous
expliquer en long et en large pendant
des minutes et des minutes qu'il n'y
avait pas de problème donc la vérité
ailleurs et on aura le le temps du débat
sur la deuxième question monsieur
ministre vous savez que les communistes
sont pour le nucléaire et les énergies
renouvelables
avec toujours un préalable je le redirai
un haut statut pour les salariés de la
nucléaire qui les protège et qui nous
protège et transparence totale pour les
populations donc il va falloir trouver
un autre argument parce que j'espère que
vous êtes pas venu qu'avec celui-là ce
soir pour nous expliquer que celles et
ceux qui vont s'opposer à la fusion IRSN
ASN
et collègues écologistes ont le droit et
de développer leur arguments mais on va
en développer d'autres et à chaque fois
vous allez pas pouvoir nous renvoyer
dans nos 22 m en nous expliquant que
tout quoi qu'il arrive si on est contre
cette fusion c'est qu'on est contre la
roulance du nucléaire et donc pour autre
chose je vous le dis pour notre part on
va faire valoir beaucoup d'arguments et
j'espère que vous pourrez y répondre ce
soir je vous remercie et nous voterons
donc cette question
préalable merci s'il n'y a pas d'autres
demande je vais consulter le Sénat sur
la motion tendant à opposer la question
préalable je rappelle que l'adoption de
cette motion entraînerait le rejet du
texte en discussion je rappelle l'avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement donc qui est pour cette
motion qui est
contre qui
s'abstient la motion n'est pas
adoptée nous passons à la discussion de
la motion tendant au au renvoie en
commission Monsieur Gilbert Luc Devinaz
et les membres du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain ont déposé une
motion distribuée sous le numéro 2
tendant au renvoi à la commission du
projet de loi la parole est à Monsieur
Sébastien Fagen pour le la motion pour
minutes madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre Monsieur et Madame président de
commission messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le Président de l'opexte à
contrario de mon collègue renal dantc en
moins de 6 mois de présence au Sénat me
voilà à défendre ma première motion
tendant à renvoyer le débat en
commission se dire à quel point le
contexte législatif dans lequel nous
évoluons autour de ce texte est
singulier et si le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain propose de
renvoyer le débat en commission c'est
pour une raison simple une raison qui
transcende les positions entre les
tenants de la filière nucléaire et ses
opposants et gardons-nous monsieur le
ministre durant le temps de l'examen de
ce texte les positions binaires à
l'égard de la filière nucléaire en effet
ce projet de loi souffre non seulement
d'une méthode attive mais aussi d'un
objectif hasardeux un an après la
tentative de cavalier législatif du
gouvernement alors que nous devons
entamer aujourd'hui nos débats dans
l'hémicycle aucun diagnostic aucun état
des lieux étayé des forces et des
faiblesses du système dual actuel ne
nous a été fourni et ce malgré le
travail de qualité mené par les deux
rapporteurs mais aussi le rapport mené
par l'opexte Monsieur le Président qui
plus est alors qu'un dialogue avait été
amorcé avec l'ancienne ministre de la
transition énergétique agè panirunaché
et son équipe celui-ci a été
soudainement interrompu par le
remimement ministériel qui a été pour
l'énergie synonyme de dissolution du
ministère de plein exercice dont la
filière bénéficiait jusqu'àors au-delà
des questionnements sur le bien fondé
d'inscrire l'énergie dans le
portefeuille du ministre de l'économie
au regard des spécificités de la filière
dans un contexte inédit de relance du
nucléaire il n'y a pas eu de calendrier
de travail pourtant nécessaire en amont
de la séance publique à laquelle nous
assistons aujourd'hui le point d'org de
cette méthodologie attive étant
l'absence d'audition ministériell devant
les commissions de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
et des affaires économiques il n'y a pas
de doute possible sur la nuisance
qu'entraîne cette situation sur la
qualité de examen parlementaire et sur
le respect des prérogatives de notre
assemblée cela a été rappelé tout à
l'heure avec force par la présidente
Estrosi Sasson et nous l'en remercions
plus largement notre pays reste en
attente d'une loi de programmation sur
l'énergie et le climat qui devra fixer
les grands objectifs de la programmation
plurannuelle de l'énergie et la
stratégie nationale bac carbone et
permettra de bâtir la stratégie
française pour l'énergie et le climat
ces lois de programmation sans cesse
reporté aurait dû être adopté avant le
1er juillet 2023 le gouvernement esquive
une fois FO de plus le grand débat
autour de la loi de programmation sur
l'énergie et climat qui devrait pourtant
être un préalable de la politique
énergétique de la France n'oublions pas
que la charte constitutionnel de
l'environnement prévoit que les Français
ont à connaître et doivent pouvoir
discuter des politiques énergétiques et
climatiques qui conditionneront la
durabilité la viabilité du monde de
demain pour en revenir à l'objet même du
texte il n'est pas question de remettre
en cause la volonté légitime de
réexaminer les forces et les faiblesses
de notre modèle historique de
gouvernance de la sûreté nucléaire et de
la
radioprotection il s'agit toutefois de
ne pas se laisser dicter par la
précipitation car celle-ci pourrait être
dommageable à bien des égards à un
moment où les enjeux de la relance de la
filière demandent plus que jamais de la
stabilité de la confiance et de la
transparence dommageable tout d'abord au
regard du manque d'acceptabilité de la
part des acteurs de la filière eux-mêmes
les employés de l'ASN et de l'IRSN
déplore le manque de ressources et
considère à raison que la fusion
n'apportera aura pas de réponse à ce
problème l'IRSN a subi une vague de
dimension inédite suite à l'annonce du
projet de fusion et les difficultés de
recrutement pèse désormais lourdement
sur l'établissement le risque à terme
att trait à la perte des compétences
pourtant nécessaires et indispensables à
la relance de la filière et il faut
saluer l'engagement quotidien de ces
femmes et de ces hommes au service de
l'excellence de la filière
électronucléaire française dommageable
au regard des externalités négatives de
l'optimisation d'interface entre l'ASN
et l'IRSN au détriment d'autres
interfaces tout ai essentiell la fusion
annonce par ailleurs la fin de la
complémentarité entre la modélisation et
la mesure pourtant essentielle dans le
casadre de l'expertise en situation
d'urgence et postaccidentelle
dommageable puisque la SNR ne
garantirait pas la séparation entre
l'expertise et la décision fondement de
l'intégrité du système de contrôle de la
sreté nucléaire et de la de la
radioprotection depuis
1973 date de la création du service
central de la sûreté des installations
nucléaire cette distinction est pourtant
primordiale pour supporter les décisions
et accroître la confiance du public
envers la filière il ne faut pourtant
pas croire que les acteurs qui se
battent corps et âme pour le retrait du
projet de loi ne souhaitent pas
l'optimisation de la gouvernance de la
sûreté nucleéire de la radio protection
bien au contraire ils sont forces de
proposition et celle-ci pourrai d'ors et
déjà se réaliser sans prendre le risque
d'une telle réforme la fluidité a déjà
été largement améliorée ces derniers
années en témoigne le fait que DF l'IRSN
et l'ASN ont d'ors et déjà défini des
stratégies communes d'expertise anticipé
pour le PR2 et smmr afin de sécuriser
les projets avec un planning très
détaillé sur les sujets à expertiser le
cadencement et le calendrier autant dire
que les deux institutions recherchent
sans cesse optimiser leurs interactions
et le système dual ne semble pas les
entraver le moins du monde ce que ne
veulent pas les acteurs qui s'opposent à
ce projet c'est céder à l'injonction de
l'accès accélération et ce pour une
raison bien raisonnable le risque de la
déstabilisation d'un édifice dont
l'efficacité n'est plus approuvé au
moment où nous en avons le plus besoin
il est en effet étonnant d'espérer des
résultats rapides dans le cadre d'une
relance de grande ampleur à travers une
stratégie impliquant une période
conséquente de perturbation et de
difficultés assuré dans les phases
ultérieures propre à tous les processus
de fusion n'oublions pas qu'en 2014 déjà
la Cour des comptes concluait sans
ambiguité que la fusion des deux
organismes constituerait une réponse
inappropriée par les multiples
difficultés juridiques sociales
budgétaires et matérielles qu'ell
soulèverait il est utile de garder en
chaque instant de nos échanges la
quantité d'avis défavoraable au projet
de loi qui è de la part d'institutions
scientifiques et techniques d'organismes
administratifs de juridiction financière
et bien d'autres qui méritent d'être
entendu écouter dans le cadre du débat
parlementaire je tâcherai de n'en citer
que quelques-uns et je vous invite
sincèrement à les écouter avec minutie
et intérêt avant le scrutin public
solennel de mardi prochain si vous
décidez de ne pas renvoyer le débat en
commission dès à présent la Cour des
comptes dans son rapport de 2014 précité
témoigne du fait que l'organisation dual
décideurs experts offre de nombreuses
garanties en dissociant les composantes
qui participent aux décisions prises et
nous alertent sur les difficultés de
toute nature que générerait la fusion de
l'ASN et de l'IRSN l'ANCLI l'Association
nationale des comités et commission
local d'information qui fédère les
expériences et les attentes des 35
comités et commissions locales
d'information craint une précipitation
quand les enjeux demandent de la
stabilité et de la confiance elle
s'inquiète tout particulièrement du
manque de garantie de transparence du
nouveau système de gouvernance alors
même que la participation du public est
indispensable à la confiance des
populations le Haut Comité pour la
transparence et l'information sur la
sécurité nucléaire déplore tout d'abord
la méthode par laquelle cette réforme de
la sûreté nucléaire avait été introduite
lors de l'élaboration de la loi du 22
juin 2020 23 et s'inquiète du fait que
le projet de loi ne confirme pas les
objectifs de garantie de la transparence
et de l'accès aux informations tout au
long du processus de prise de décision
la Commission nationale déontologie et
alerte en santé publique environnement
déplore quant à elle que la définition
des condition nécessaires à
l'indépendance entre l'expertise et la
décision soit confié au seul règlement
intérieur ne garantissant pas un statut
juridique
solide ce que nous souhaitons monsieur
le ministre c'est ass un dialogue plus
apaisé construit et efficace c'est nous
assurer que la marche à suivre est celle
qui nous mènera bel et bien vers une
relance acceptée et ambitieuse de la
filière nucléaire française pour cela il
nous semble que la seule voie
envisageable est celle d'une décision
nourrie par lappte du temps de réflexion
préalable impliquant l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés par la relance du
nucléaire de la population des
territoires modelés par l'industrie
nucléaire jusqu'aux équipes des
établissements dédiés à la sécurité et à
la sûreté nucléaire en passant par les
comités et commissions locales
d'information ainsi au regard de la
multitude des avis négatifs formulés à
l'égard de ce projet de loi de ses
conséquences non maîtrisées et des
lacunes manifestes dans les différents
scénarios expertisés et singulièrement
sur le renforcement du système dual le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain vous demande d'approuver ce
renvoi en commission je vous remercie
merci Monsieur fagnan je n'ai pas été
saisie de demande de parole contre la
motion je vais donc demander l'avis de
la commission monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la
Présidente je ne reviens pas sur les
nombreux points communs avec la question
préalable sur lequel j'ai répondu à
l'instant que Sébastien Fagan vient de
développer je voudrais juste répondre à
un argument avancé dans l'objet de cette
motion vous évoquez le report de la loi
de programmation sur l'énergie et le
climat qui devra fixer les grands
objectifs de la PPE et de la stratégie
nationale bas carbone je regrette
également l'absence de discussion
parlementair sur le sujet en raison
notamment de la suppression des articles
programmatiques du projet de loi
souveraineté énergétique il est en effet
indispensable que nous n'ayons que nous
ayons dans cet hémicycle un débat sur la
stratégie française pour l'énergie et le
climat mais quel rapport cependant avec
le texte que nous étudions aujourd'hui
la stratégie énergétique et la
gouvernance de la sûreté nucléaire sont
de sujets totalement distinct et pour
ces raisons donc ça sera un avis
défavorable présenté par la Commission
merci monsieur le rapporteur quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre d'abord l'avis que je poserai à
Monsieur Fagan ou la réponse que je
pourrais faire à Monsieur Guay mérite
une précision dans mon empressement à
répondre à Ron je faisais référence au
fait qu'il était lui fondamentalement
hostile à la relance du projet nucléaire
et donc qu'il utilisait cette question
cette motion de rejet pour être capable
de mobiliser tout les arguments à sa
disposition pour être capable d'y
parvenir ça n'était pas une manière de
dire qu'être hostile à texte veut
nécessa Clement dire être hostile au
processus de
relance ensuite vous pointez deux choses
monsieur Fanan un un sujet sur le fait
qu'il n'y aurait pas eu assez de temps
et de un certain nombre de questions
précises sur le temps l'argument qui
était valable au moment de la navette
parlementaire et du processus initial a
été gommé par le fait que vous nous
avons collectivement fait confiance à
l'opexte grâce à la présidente prima en
prenant le temps ensuite d'obtenir un
texte qui soit transpartisan qui soit
examiné par tout le monde et le regard
que je porte sur le travail de l'OPEX et
que précisément il a non seulement pris
son temps mais il a été capable
d'objectiver les choses et ça s'est fait
avec en complément un rapport de plus de
200 pages revenant sur des quantités
d'auditions qui ont eu lieu ensuite sur
les questions proprement dites c'est à
ça que sert le débat en séance le débat
en commission a eu lieu les points et
certains méritent d'être soulevés c'est
pas en renvoyant le sujet en commission
c'est en l'examinant dans l'hémicycle
que vous pourrez avoir des assurances
sur les attentes que vous avez donc ce
sera un avis défavorable du gouvernement
merci monsieur le ministre nous nous oui
nous passons aux explications de vote
monsieur Dantec pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire oui merci
madame la Présidente je voudrais dire
avec Christophe B avec qui il nous
arrive d'échanger de manière plus
structurée que il s'engage dans une voie
extrêmement dangereuse si parce qu'on
est plutôt
antinucléaire les arguments donnés sur
la sécurité sont dis
c'est extrêmement problématique pour une
partie du débat public en France et
alors là je je regarde phppe gr je
regarde ma jeunesse mais j'ai
l'impression de revenir à plogof où
c'était comme ça et o ça ne faisait que
radicaliser les oppositions et à la fin
au moins sur certains territoires le
nucléaire a battu en retraite sur toute
la Bretagne de la Loire Atlantique au
finistè donc je crois qu'il faut
distinguer absolument les débats nous
avons un débat aujourd'hui qui n'est pas
sur le nucléaire qui est sur le risque
et je suis intervenu notamment en tant
qu'ancien vice-président d'une grande
métropole qui a connu un nuage toxique
qui a connu de de de graves
problèmes je le dis vraiment monsieur le
ministre on peut pas aller sur un débat
aussi caricatural et je pense que
certaines interventions ce soir
viendront de pronucléaire qui ne pour
autant ne sont pas d'accord du tout avec
cette évolution je le redis et toutes
vos interventions ne nous rassurent pas
si on perd la triangulation si on perd
la capacité d'autonomie de l'expertise à
se poser des questions qui ne sont pas
liées aux décisions qu'il faut prendre
de plus en plus dans l'urgence et toutes
vos interventions disent qu'il y a
urgence si on perd ça on fragilise très
profondément la sécurité et la sûreté
nucléaire donc c'est un enjeu majeur
qu'on soit pour ou antinucléaire et par
ailleurs j'évolue dans le temps j'étais
antinucléaire pour des raisons
environnementales aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt pour des raisons économique du
photovoltaïque à 30 € du nucléaire à 100
€ ça marche pas à horizon 10 15 ans et
pour finir madame présidente en quelques
secondes je m'excuse de ne pas être
présent sur ce débat j'ai pris des
engagements auprès de la la présidence
belge de l'Union européenne et nous
ouvrons demain le premier grand sommet
européen sur l'adaptation donc je ne
pourrais être présent et vous m'envoyez
absolument désolé merci Monsieur dc je
n'ai pas été saisi d'autres demandes
d'explication de vote je vais donc
consulter le Sénat sur la motion de
renvoi à la commission rappelle l'avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient la motion n'est
pas adopté dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Gilbert Luc Devinaz pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 6
[Applaudissements]
minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues pour réussir
notre transition énergétique et se
passer des énergies fossiles il nous
faut de l'électricité beaucoup
d'électricité même pour obtenir de
l'hydrogène vert des biocarburants il
faut de l'électricité si nous attendons
toujours l'examen de la loi structurante
de programmation énergétique
l'accélération de la production
nucléaire en revanche est lancé car nous
aurons besoin du nucléaire pour faire
face aux défis qui nous attendent dans
un contexte géopolitique et climatique
de plus en plus
incertain l'énergie nucléaire est un
défi organisationnel et humain autant
que technique procédural et financier
notre système repose sur piliers
assurant un équilibre solide et qui
s'est construit avec notre histoire
nucléaire pourquoi il y a 25 ans la
France a mis en place un système dual
singulier rappelé par notre collègue
Piednoir suite aux accid nucléairire et
notamment tchernbyy le système fut
réinterrogé il est décidé de valoriser
la démonstration permanente de la Sûreté
Nucléaire s'appuyant sur le dépass
scientifique contradictoire autour du
risque et rendu indépendant du pouvoir
politique l'objectif était de créer un
choc de confiance auprès de nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens il est
atteint au regard des enquêtes d'opinion
cette évolution continue du système
français qui repose sur la démonstration
de sûreté et de sécurité s'articule
depuis le modèle historique du CEA par
une différenciation culturelle entre
l'opérateur et son approche industriel
l'IRSN avec son approche scientifique
des risques l'ASN avec son approche
réglement fondé sur le concept de
conformité le 4è pilier la confiance de
la société civile pour autant
aujourd'hui avec le développement de
l'Internet nous sommes dans une société
de réseau et de désinformation
permanente tous les moyens de semer le
doute et d'anéantir la confiance sont en
place et la confiance cela passe par la
meilleure transparence possible si
l'expertise ne doit pas dicter la
décision la décision ne doit pas
étouffer la transparence de expertise
cette réforme induit le doute et
affaiblit la confiance avec cette fusion
le gouvernement si le 4e pied de la
chaise sur lequel est assis
l'acceptabilité du nucléaire au moment
de sa montée en puissance la création de
l'IRSN et le statut d'autorité
administrative indépendante pour laasn
reposé sur trois exigences la
transparence la nécessité d'éclairer les
décisions publiques en matière de risque
nucléaire et radiologique l'indépendant
de la décision publique une 4è exigence
essentielle propre à l'environnement
nucléaire français consiste à un
équilibre entre la sûreté réglée
c'est-à-dire la capacité à respecter les
règles et à démontrer la conformité de
celle-ci propre à l'ASN et la sûreté
gérée c'est-à-dire la capacité assurer
la sûreté en toutes circonstances même
imprévu ou imprévisible propre à l'IRSN
cet équilibre ne peut pas être prescrit
mais résulte des choix organisationnels
ce double débat peut donner une
impression de complexité au système il
est pourtant indispensable à maintenir
une bonne capacité de détection des
signaux faibles et de limiter la simple
affirmation de conformité
potentiellement nuisible alors pourquoi
aujourd'hui réformer ce système sur la
base d'une analyse incomplète et pour
quel objectif dans un contexte de plus
en plus instable l'étude d'impact
n'apporte aucune réponse ni ni sur les
éventuels dysfonctionnements actuels ni
sur les amarations apportées par la
nouvelle organisation nous relançons le
nucléaire prolongeons des réacteurs
acceptons l'arrivée de réacteurs
modulaires dans un contexte de
changement climatique et d'instabilité
géopolitique dans le même temps nous
déstabilisons tout notre système de
sûreté de sécurité pour aller plus vite
aller plus vite vers quoi l'accident
l'organisation proposée par ce texte va
induire des contreperformances qui ne
pourront être apprécié que dans la durée
d'abord la viabilité de notre capacité
de recherche ensuite la proportionnalité
des mesures de
sûreté les liens de sûreté de sécurité
entre le nucléaire civil et de défense
enfin la transparence et la confiance
l'irns a permis le partage des
connaissances avec la société civile
soutenu et encouragé par le débat public
le projet de loi met également en péril
à court terme notre organisation il
fragilise les équipes dans un contexte
clé de relance du nucléaire la fusion
conduira à un choc culturel il
déconnecte la sûreté nucléaire de la
sécurité nucléaire les deux sont
pourtant intimement liés il réduit la
transparence au bon vouloir de la
nouvelle structure qui opérera ses
propres choix de publication il renvoie
l'essentiel à un futur règlement
intérieur qui ne dit rien de l'équilibre
organisationnel le calendrier esquisé de
construction la nouvelle gén des
réacteurs nucléaires laisse largement le
temps de réformer avec toutes les
précautions souhaitables notre système
de contrôle et de sûreté nucléaire oui
il y a urgence à prendre le temps de
bien faire plus vite moins cher et plus
efficace cela ne veut pas dire piétiner
les intérêts scientifiques au bénéfice
d'intérêts économique et
financiers la parole est à notre
collègue Jean-Claude anglar pour le
groupe les républicains pour 4
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
commion monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues je ne peux pas commencer mon
propos sans dire un mot sur la jeunèe de
ce texte le 3 février 2023 à l'issue du
Conseil de politique nucléaire était
annoncé la volonté de fusionner
l'Institut de radio protetion de la
sûreté nucléaire avec l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire une réforme qui devait
intervenir par le biais d'amendements
gouvernementaux au projet de loi
d'accélération du nucléaire et ce sans
concertation évaluation préalable ou
encore avis du Conseil
d'État une réforme qui devait également
intervenir sans examen par le Sénat
puisque les deux amendements présentés
par le gouvernement l'ont été devant
l'Assemblée nationale alors que le Sénat
s'était pour sa part déjà prononcé fort
heureusement ces amendements ont été
rejetés par l'Assemblée nationale et
n'ont pas été réintroduits en commission
mixte paritaire de sorte que la loi
promulguée au mois de juin dernier ne
comporte aucune disposition relative à
cette fusion
quelle était l'urgence que justifiait
une réforme aussi mal engagée la semaine
dernière à l'occasion du prononcer de
son discours de politique générale le
Premier ministre a réaffirmé le rôle
primordial du Sénat et rappelé qu'il n'y
a pas de République sans
bicamérisme pouvons-nous en conclure que
ce type de pratique ne se reproduira
plus quoi qu'il en soit le refus du
Parlement a donné le temps de la
réflexion et il en faut deux projets de
loi l' organique et le second ordinaire
proposant trois réformes techniques ont
finalement été déposées ces derniers ont
fait l'objet d'une étude d'impact d'un
avis du Conseil d'État et même depuis
plusieurs semaines d'un examen par le
Sénat il ne s'agit plus seulement de
fusionner laasn et l'IRSN mais de
simplifier les règles de la commande
publique applicable au projets de
production de recherche ou de stockage
nucléaire et de repositionner le haut
commissaire de l'énergie
atomique du Parlement a laissé le temps
à l'OPEX d'analyser cette réorganisation
pardon je tiens ici à saluer la
réactivité de la commission des affaires
économiques du Sénat qui a saisi l'OPEX
dès le mois d'avril
2023 il ne faut pas se tromper l'enjeu
de ce texte est bien la Sûreté
Nucléaire ainsi que la très justement
rappelé Michael manjon historien du
nucléaire devant l'OPEX l'histoire nous
montre que le système et son
fonctionnement sont sont une cause
profonde d'accident nucléaair en
conséquence toute décision de réforme du
système a un impact direct ou indirect
sur la sûreté nucléire et doit être
analysé en profondeur la réforme
proposée consiste notamment à fusionner
l'IRSN établissement public industrielle
et commercial chargé d'effectuer les
recherches sur les risques liés à la à
la radioactivité qui compte plus de 1700
agent et l'ASN gendarme du nucléaire
autorité administrative indépendante
charg du contrôle de la Sûreté Nucléaire
via des contrôles de recommandations et
des avis qui compent environ 500 agents
à compter du 1er avril 2005 la nouvelle
autorité de contrôle en sûreté nucléaire
et en radioprotection autorité
administrative indépendante reprendra
l'ensemble des missions de l'ASN et de
l'IRSN une fusion qui s suite des
inquiétudes légitimes risque de
désorganisation de perte des compétences
augmentation des coûts confusion
d'émission dégradation de l'évaluation
des risques ou encore perte de
transparence vis-à-vis du public si le
système actuel a donné satisfaction
cette réforme est justifiée par les
perspectives de développement du
nucléaire inégal depuis le plan Mesmer
et la nécessité de faire face aux enjeux
majeurs de sa souveraineté énergétique
l'objectif est de fluidifier un niveau
inchangé de sûreté nucléaire l'OPEX a
confirmé l'opportunité d'une telle
fusion et formulé diverses
recommandations dont la plupart on été
reprise par nos rapporteurs Pascal
Martin et Patrick que je salue c'est une
réforme consolidée qui nous est soumise
si elle est correctement réalisée les
avantages de cette fusion seront
multiples efficacité accrue meilleure
adaptation aux enjeux contemporains de
la Sûreté Nucléaire amélioration de la
gestion de crise ou bien encore
renforcement de
l'attractivité plusieurs points
mériteront une vigilance particulière et
nous aurons l'occasion d'en parler mais
sans sans augmentation significatif des
effectifs affectés à la aux activités de
la sité nucléaire civile et de Radi
protection tant en matière de de
contrôle d'expertise de ce recherche
cette fusion sera en leée pourrait être
un échec pour la sûreté de notre pays en
tout cas avec les réserves que nous
avons exprimé le groupe des Républicains
votera le projet de loi ainsi modifié
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est à Christopher Zurek pour la Réunion
administrative des sénateurs ne figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe pour 3
minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
développement et le déploiement de
nouvelles structures électroon nucléaire
constitue une ardente obligation pour
assurer à la France son indépendance sa
souveraineté et une croissance
respectueuse de l'environnement le texte
qui nous est ainsi présenté sous son
aspect fortement technique témoigneune
volonté renouvelée d'investir dans nos
centrales nucléaires nous ne pouvons
donc que nous féliciter d'une victoire
idéologique pendant des décennies nous
avons défendu seul ou pres le maintien
de notre puissance nucléaire au milieu
des turiférires de la décroissance et
des pourfondeurs Européens du du
nucléaire soutien Infiné du charbon la
réunion des deux autorités que sont
l'autorité de sreté nucléaire et l'IRSN
a provoqué nous le savons des
inquiétudes tant à l'Assemblée nationale
qu'auprès des professionnels de la
gouvernance du nucléaire nous nous
félicitons que le gouvernement ait
entendu l'avis des chambres en proposant
un texte réel pour organiser la création
de l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire et de
radiprotection
le travail de qualité du Sénat a permis
de lisibiliser le texte d'améliorer la
publicité des rapports et des
communications qui seront donné par la
nouvelle agence et garantir la qualité
de l'expertise donnée et la célérité des
autorisations transmises néanmoins nous
exprimons une inquiétude devant une
bureaucratisation tendantielle de notre
industrie nucléaire ce texte devra en
pratique répondre à son objectif
d'amélioration de la rapidité des
délivrants autorisation de construction
ou de renouvellement des centrales si la
sécurité doit être une priorité bien
évidemment la prudence ne doit pas rimer
avec impotence notre parc
électronucléaire a été construit sans
l'existence de ce dualisme d'instance
qui avait dans les années précédentes
contribué à affaiblir la confiance des
des Français envers leur centrale
nucléaire et à ralentir le processus de
croissance industrielle et de création
de nouvelles centrales depuis l'accident
nucléaire de Fukushima les activistes
antinucléaires ont porté une
désinformation irresponsable sur cette
source d'énergie pourtant propre
souveraine et de bon marché ce travail
lancinant porter ses fruits empoisonnés
particulièrement auprès de notre
jeunesse et dans les gouvernements qui
se sont succédés depuis lors le résultat
notre filière nucléaire a été
considérablement affléblie et fragilisé
mettant en péril la stabilité de notre
production électrique et participant à
alourdir sans cesse les factures des
ménages et des entreprises depuis 7 ans
le gouvernement a multiplié les
atermoiements autour de la filière
nucléaire annonçant dans un premier
temps sa volonté d'abaisser à 50 % sa
part dans le mix énergétique avant de
revenir sur ses décisions et
d'entreprendre bien des années trop tard
un plan d'accélération et de
renouvellement de notre parc largement
encore insuffisant sans surprise pour
autant nous soutiendrons ce texte et
tous les amendements permettant de
l'améliorer tout en conservant son
principe premier d'une autorité unique
placé sous le regard des chambres et des
Français pour garantir la sûreté de
notre parc électronucléaire et le
développement plus rapide de nouvelles
centrales absolument nécessaire à une
énergie Nationale Souveraine permettant
une croissance durable respectueuse
environnement et symbole du génie
français je vous
remercie chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur pierre- Jean Rochette pour le
groupe les indépendant pour 5
minutes madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre vous avez compris que
unanimement mes collègues moiême sommes
heureux de vous accueillir ce soir pour
parler de ce PPL monsieur le Président
de la Commission messieurs les
rapporteurs
questionner le fonctionnement et la
gouvernance de la sûreté nucléaire et de
la radiprotection est une nécessité ce
sujet se pense bien évidemment à long
terme tout comme la souveraineté
énergétique dont nous attendons très
prochainement et avec impatience le
projet de loi je me permets d'appuyer
sur ce point car les enjeux prochains
pour la France et l'Union européenne
sont colossaux en matière d'indépendance
énergétique mais pas que la menace Trump
aux États-Unis est un remake qui serait
bien qui serait bien apre et menace
sérieuse la montée des populistes aux
prochaines élections européennes est
annoncée dans tous les sondages
d'opinion l'essentielle souveraineté
européenne pourrait bien malgré elle se
retrouver en étau entre l'extrême droite
américaine et certaines forces d'extrême
droite européenne quels que soient les
résultats de ces élections et comme
l'ont prouvé les deux dernières années
notre souveraineté passe par notre
indépendance énergétique je tiens donc à
saluer la volonté de relance de la
filière nucléaire depuis le discours de
Belfort depuis toujours à titre
personnel je défends cette énergie dont
la France peut être fière d'être un des
leaders mondiaux je souhaite apporter
mon soutien à l'action gouvernementale
sur la place du nucléaire en Europe
maintenant que de moins en moins de pays
remettent en cause son rôle d'énergie
déterminante il est temps de transformer
il est l'heure de transformer
l'essai c'est un terme rubbistique que
j'affectionne tout particulièrement si
la sûreté nucléaire et la
radioprotection se pensent à long terme
comme je le disais cela se pense aussi
avec flexibilité et possibilité
d'amélioration constante j'ai entendu
les critiques sur le timing de ce PJL et
je peux les entendre il faut néanmoins
rappeler que nous travaillons déjà sur
ce sujet depuis plusieurs mois et
maintenant que la relance est amorcée il
est temps d'agir de manière générale la
relance du nucléaire ouvre à de nouveaux
défis beaucoup ont été énoncé mais ça ne
fait pas de mal de les rappeler je parle
bien sûr du nouveau nucléaire des smmr
de are parc vieillissant de
l'indispensable adaptation au
dérèglement climatiques ou encore de la
sécurité du marché de l'électricité qui
est au-delà bien entendu un enjeu
économique et également géopolitique
nous parlions encore récemment dans cet
hémicycle de la réforme de ce marché
européen que nous souhaitons quasiment
tous les enjeux sont immenses les
réponses doivent l'être tout autant je
salue donc le travail qui a été fourni
au sein des deux commissions saisies je
partage en revanche les craintes
majeures évoqué par les divers acteurs
et notamment les deux rapporteurs la
distinction entre expertise et décision
est l'une des principales c'est pourquoi
la création d'une commission d'éthique
et de déontologie ainsi que le recours
possible à des groupes permettant
permanent d'experts devrait renforcer
l'architecture de l'asnr et ainsi
rassurer je crois en l'importance d'un
dialogue constant entre la nouvelle asnr
et la filière nucléaire où la recherche
et l'innovation sont importantes il
faudra néanmoins être attentif au
conflit d'intérêts et je pense que les
dispositions de l'article 2 notamment
participent à notre vigilance la
transparence sera également clé
l'information doit donc pouvoir circuler
avec le public et les acteurs concernés
cela contribue à l'acceptation
indispensable des citoyens le rôle
qu'URA lopex complété par les
commissions compétentes du Parlement est
tout aussi essentiel quand il est
question de transparence les missions et
attributions de la SNR sont
déterminantes tout comme son règlement
intérieur après les discussion en
commission à la vue des amendements
déposés et en attend en en entendant
pardon les premières interventions aucun
doute ce sujet fait partie des plus
discutés il sera la clé de la réussite
de laasnr et je forme le vœux que son
contenu prenne en compte les enjeux que
nous avons pu soulever dernier point et
non des moindres et je rejoindrai mes
collègues qui ont parlé de ce sujet
c'est un point capital les salariés et
leurs compétences les conditions de
leurs transfert les rémunér et les
conditions d'accès à l'emploi ont un
impact déterminant sur l'attractivité de
ces métiers d'excellence nous relançons
le nucléaire et avons la chance de
pouvoir compter sur un vivier de gens
compétents il faut leur permettre de
rester en France de servir ce pays de
continuer à faire évoluer leurs
compétences les voir partir au service
de puissance étrangère serait un échec
majeur de cette réforme pour cela et ce
sera mon dernier point nous avons besoin
d'allouer les moyens nécessaires au
secteur nucléaire en conclus jet de Lo
est une facette non négligeable de la
reconstruction amorcée l'indépendance
énergétique de la France et de l'Europe
c'est pourquoi malgré les points de
vigilance évoqu et que nous garderons à
l'œil et parce qu'il apporte des
solutions le groupe Les Indépendants
voter en sa
faveur merci la parole est à Madame
Denise pour le groupe Union centriste et
pour 4
minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs
madamees et monieurs les président des
commissions lorsque le gouvernement a
tenté de fusionner en 2023 l'ASN avec
l'IRSN beaucoup d'entre nous ont émis
des doutes sur ce projet et demandé son
retrait
en effet cette réforme posait de
nombreuses questions qui ne pouvait
trouver de réponse satisfaisantes dans
les délais qui nous étit imparti
heureusement le gouvernement nous a
écouté permettant aux parlementaires de
mieux examiner la pertinence de cette
réforme sa faisabilité ses limites et le
calendrier à suivre si l'on choisissait
de la menir à terme à ce titre le
rapport de mieur Piednoir et fugit pour
le compte de l'OPEX est venu utilement
rappeler que la relance du nucléaire
passe par la maîtrise de multiples
enjeux construction de nouveaux
réacteurs PR2 évolution technologique
prolongation de la vie des réacteurs
existant gestion des déchets nucléaires
adaptation des infrastructures au
changement climatiques et au risques
cyber démantellement des centrales en
fin de vie et cetera autant de défis
auxquels S aoué des imprévus tels que
les problèmes de corrosion sous
contrainte rencontrés récemment sur
notre parc avec le recul ce contexte
semble plaider efficacement en faveur
d'une seule entité issue d'un
rapprochement entre IRSN et ASN nous
voici donc prêt à débattre de cette
fusion 1 an après son annonce originel
ayant pris à cœur le conseil de l'OPEX
sur la nécessité de tenir un cal endrier
resserré de mise en œuvre de la réforme
de son côté le gouvernement a profité de
ce délai pour affiner sa copie désormais
étayé par une étude d'impact bienvenue
le texte établit ainsi la csnr en
interlocuteur unique et indépendant
chargé du contrôle et de l'instruction
des dossiers de sûreté et de
radioprotection ouvert sur la société
doté de moyens internes forts tout en
ayant la faculté de les compléter é
auprès de partenaires externes et
pouvant s'appuyer à la fois sur une
recherche de renommée internationale et
sur des groupe permanent d'experts
propices à la confrontation des points
de vue par ailleurs dans un contexte de
tension sur les recrutement dans la
filière nucléaire liée à sa relance
cette évolution doit permettre de
regrouper les compétences rares tout en
améliorant l'attractivité de ces métiers
au travers d'une diversité des statut
possi des parcours de carrière y compris
sur le plan géographique et des mesures
d'ordre salarial permettant d'engager un
nécessaire rééquilibrage par rapport au
secteur privé enfin j'en viens aux
avancées apportées lors de l'examen de
ce texte en commission grâce à
l'excellent travail mené par mes
collègues rapporteurs Pascal Martin et
Patrick chaise dont je salue
l'engagement je me réjouis par exemple
de la la consécration législative des
groupes permanents d'experts ceci
garantissant une évaluation impartiale
ainsi qu'une prise de décision forte
fondée sur les meilleures pratiques et
les connaissances les plus récentes en
outre j'approuve l'inscription dans la
loi du principe de publication des
résultats d'expertise de l'asnr qui
vaudra également pour les avis des
groupes permanents d'experts comme le
veut la pratique actuelle la crédibilité
du système de sûreté nucléaire repose
sur cette exigence de transparence
absolument indispensable pour assurer
l'acceptabilité de la relance de l'atome
dans notre pays ces mesures essentielles
viennent parachever un projet de loi
ambitieux et exigeant et c'est pourquoi
notre groupe centriste votera en faveur
de ce texte je vous remerci merci la
parole est à Monsieur Daniel salmon pour
le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs nous
l'avons exprimé lors des discussions de
ces deux motions le texte que nous
discutons soulève pour nous de graves
inquiétudes nous nous opposons vous le
savez au fondement même de cette réforme
le démantelllement deirsn qui a su
démontrer historiquement sa rigueur et
son indépendance est en effet
incompréhensible sauf à imaginer que
l'on souhaite par là affaiblir un
contrepouvoir capable d'apporter de
l'objectivité dans le débat sur
l'énergie nucléaire car au risque de
vous surprendre la répétition en boucle
des termes fluidification simplification
pour justifier le démantelllement de l'
RSN n'a pas suffit à nous convaincre de
son bien fondé ces mots sonnent creux
alors que c'est reconnu y compris à
l'étranger notre organisation de sûreté
nucléaire repose sur le système dual
fonctionne même si elle pourrait bien
sûr être améliorée et si très peu
d'arguments en faveur de la fusion nous
ont été présenté la liste des risques
générés par cette réforme est quant à
elle très bien étayée l'avis de la
commission nationale de déontologie et
des alertes en matière de santé publique
et d'environnement suite à la sisine que
nous avions réalisé en février dernier
est très claire le moyen le plus sûr
d'assurer la séparation et la gestion
avec la recherche et l'expertise
consiste à maintenir ces missions au
sein de personnes morales différentes le
fait d'avoir un dialogue tripartite
entre EDF ASN et IRSN permet une
triangulation dans l'analyse de risque
et une diversité dans les points de vue
elle est garante de l'anticipation et
d'une meilleure analyse des enjeux liés
aux décisions en matière de sûreté
affaiblir ce système semble dangereux
alors que les catastrophes technologiqu
ont souvent dans l'histoire été lié à
des problèmes organisationnels cela a
été est clairement démontré par les
chercheurs étudiants les accidents que
ce soit dans le domaine spatial chimique
aéronautique ou nucléaire et cela
rejoint les avis des experts au
management des organisations les fusions
sont bien souvent synonyme de confusion
faire converger les pratiques les
fonctionnements les cultures de deux
organismes génèent de l'instabilité
prend du temps et le succès monsieur le
ministre n'est pas garanti autant
d'éléments qui donnent encore une fois
l'impression d'un texte destiné à
faciliter la relance à marche forcée du
nucléaire en affaiblissant les
contrepouvoirs quitte à ce que cela se
fasse au détriment du niveau de sûeté et
la mise en œuvre de cette réforme ne
vient pas nous rassurer à cet égard bien
au contraire son calendrier tout d'abord
est extrêmement rapide et à même de
générer de fortes désorganisations une
entrée en vigueur au 1er janvier 2025
semble irréaliste alors que l'on parle
de relocaliser les quelques 1700
collaborateurs de l'IRSN de faire
travailler ensemble des cultures
différentes c'est organisations
arrivrive au moment où une augmentation
d'activité pour la SCN et l'IRSN est
présente sans garantie de renforcement
de ces moyens humain et avec à la clé
des conditions de travail fortement
dégradées l'Inter syndicale de l'IRSN
est d'ailleurs inquiète des conséquence
de cette fusion pour les salariés et sur
le niveau de sûreté qui pourrait en
résulter car c'est l' excusez-moi car
c'est l'attractivité de ces métiers et
donc notre capacité à gérer le risque
nucléaire qui est en jeu autre point de
forte inquiétude la mise en place au
sein de la future autorité de la
séparation entre expertise et décision
pilier fondamental de notre sûreté
nucléaire est insuffisante le texte
n'apporte pas de garantie de
l'indépendance des experts alors que
l'IRSN était reconnu pour fournir des
données de façon robuste et objectif
autre principe clé malmené par ce texte
la transparence et le dialogue avec la
société civile qui apparaissent en net
recul par rapport au système existant
l'IRSN avait réussi à nouer un dialogue
avec la société civile et est reconnu
comme participant efficacement à la
démocratie technique et environnementale
rien nindique que la future entité
jouera ce rôle à forciori quand la
publicité de ces travaux n'est pas
suffisamment garantie loin de la
fluidité promise cette réforme semble
bancale et purement inabouti comme en
témoigne le renfoi de nombreux points un
futur règlement intérieur dont
l'élaboration n'est que peu encadré sur
ces points la Commission àdd a tenté il
faut le reconnaître d'améliorer la copie
du gouvernement et je le salue qui
n'apportait aucune garantie ces
modifications sont aujourd'hui remises
en cause par ce gouvernement nous sommes
donc plus qu'inquiet monsieur le
ministre face à cette volonté désormais
très claire d'acter des retours en
arrière sur la transparence et
l'indépendance de l'expertise
rappelons-le nous parlons ici de la
sécurité de nos concitoyens et de notre
environnement et pas seulement
aujourd'hui pour des siècles nous nous
opposons à la relance nucléaire nous
avons à mainreprise souligné l'impasse
financière et les risques liés à cette
technologie mais que l'on soit pour ou
contre l'énergie atomique la maîtrise du
risque d'accident nucléire reste une
priorité et doit conditionner tous nos
choix nous nous opposons donc plus que
jamais à ce texte et si nous proposerons
des amendements pour tenter de limiter
les risques qu'il comportte nous vous
appelons chers collègues à voter contre
ce projet de loi dangereux et inabouti
et je vous le dis avec forceci chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Fabien Guay pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste kanaki
pour 5
minutes madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues pour les
communistes la relance et le
développement de la filière nucléaire
française doit s'appuyer sur deux pieds
en premier lieu un statut de haut niveau
pour les salariés y compris les
sous-traitants qui reconnaî leur
qualification avec un haut niveau de
rémunération et un statut qui les
protège et donc qui nous protège mais
également une transparence totale en
terme de sûreté pour permettre
l'adhésion totale des citoyens et
citoyennes ainsi que les élus locaux au
moment où l'on s'apprête à relancer le
nucléaire français vous décidez dans le
même temps de réformer son contrôle de
sûreté très bien mais dans quel but et
pourquoi jusqu'à là cette mission
d'intérêt général reposait sur un
système dual composé de laasn gendarme
du nuccléaire et son expert technique
l'IRSN système é prouvé qui n'a eu de
cesse d'évoluer pour garantir une
conciliation entre la entre une
diversité de points de vue permettant
d'éviter le monolitisme décisionnel
vecteur on le sait de risque si des
pistes d'amélioration sont toujours
envisageables le gouvernement a pourtant
fait le choix d'une restruct tion dont
le bien fondé a été très largement
contesté par les personnels de l'IRSN
mais aussi de l'ASN mais aussi de
nombreux chercheurs et scientifiques
alors Monsieur le Ministre pourquoi
défaire ce qui fonctionne aucun argument
que vous avez développé ne tient la
route la vérité est donc ailleurs le
gouvernement comme parfois l'exploitant
a toujours considérer que l'IRSN était
un frein dans le développement du
nucléaire et que pour le relancer il
faut aller vite et fort et en réalité en
finir avec l'IRSN le résultat de tout
cela c'est la désorganisation que nous
constatons actuellement principalement
lié au fait que vous n'avez pas nommé de
préfigurateur à la fusion et qu'ils
sençu à raison une grande incertitude
chez les salariés de laasn comme ceux de
l'IRSN pour l'IRSN près de la moitié de
l'équipe de sécurité à démissionné il ne
reste que trois personnes au traitement
des déchets radioactifs et deux à la
supervision des 56 réacteurs nucléaires
voici donc les résultats de vos choix
politiques les salariés s'en vont déjà
alors pouvez-vous répondre à des
questions simples quels concours de
recrutement seront prévus à quel niveau
de rémunération et combien de postes
seront ouverts il faut que vous nous
répondiez clairement sur vos ambitions
pour assurer l'attractivité de cette
nouvelle entité de sûreté nucléaire
d'autant que tous nos amendements
concernant les salariés la question
sociale ont été déclaré irreceva je vous
le dis c'est assez inacceptable en fait
votre réforme est aussi comme il en
devient l'habitude une réforme qui se
veut de rationalité économique cependant
les 13 groupes de travail mis en place
démontre que dans un certain nombre de
domaines cette fusion coûtera plus cher
par exemple la coordination entre les
différents outils informatique 400 d'un
côté 40 de l'autre mettra au minimum
plusieurs mois voir anné à se réaliser
et ne sera jamais prêt au 1er janvier
2025 autre exemple alors que la sûreté
nucléaire militaire jusqu'àors dévolue à
l'IRSN au même titre que le nucléaire
civil risque d'être transféré au
ministère des armées des divergences
d'avis de sûreté sont à craindre en plus
d'un recul sur la transparence notamment
pour le cas des réacteurs SMR une
technologie transposée du domaine
militaire au civil l'impossibilité de
mobilité interne résultant de cette
restructuration fera perdre des
connaissances précieuses cela doit nous
alerter d'autant que ces nouveaux
réacteurs seraient confiés à des acteurs
privés qui ne raisonne qu'en terme de
profit et non d'intérêt général plus
généralement le présent projet de loi ne
garantit pas le même dégré
d'indépendance et de sérénité de
l'expertise qui doit se baser uniquement
sur des faits scientifiques et rester
hermétique à la faisabilité industrielle
ou aux intérêts économiques et
commerciaux actuellement la production
nucléaire est une activité hautement
capitalistique les enjeux économiques
liés aux décisions de démarrage ou
d'arrêt des centrales sont donc
prignants si l'objectif d'en minimiser
la durée pour des raisons économiques et
compréhensibles nous considérons que
l'impératif de sûreté doit toujours
primé plus encore ce projet ne garantit
pas une pérennité des exigences
actuelles en terme de transparence et de
démocratie environnementale qui sont
pourtant des valeurs fondamentales et un
maillon essentiel de la confiance des
cito citoyens et citoyennes envers le
secteur nucléaire si la publication des
avis l'IRSN est résulté auparavant d'un
fondement légal le texte tel qu'il nous
est présenté relègue cette possibilité
de manière vague au au domaine du
règlement intérieur ainsi contrairement
à la communication gouvernementale qui
assure que ce projet de restructuration
vise à renforcer fluidifier le contrôle
de la srté nucléaire nombre de ces
effets potentiels sembl être à rebours
des objectifs annoncés c'est pour tout
ces raisons que nous voterons contre je
vous remercie merci la parole est à
notre collègue Raphaël dobé pour le
groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
sociale
européen pour 5
minutes madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame monsieur le les
présidents de commission messieurs les
Rapp rorteur mes chers collègues je dois
avouer que j'ai eu bien du mal et
beaucoup de mes collègues avec moi à me
forger une conviction solide quant à la
pertinence du projet de loi qui nous est
soumis ce n'est pas faute d'avoir
recherché des arguments objectifs
au-delà des clivages idéologiques mais
forcé de reconnaître que beaucoup de
questions demeurent après analyse du
texte et que nul n'est en capacité de
prédire les conséquences de son adoption
ou de son rejet
une chose que nous savons avec
certitude c'est la reconnaissance
nationale et internationale dont
bénéficie notre système dual de sûreté
nucléaire aujourd'hui c'est aussi la
confiance que les Français lui accordent
un système agissant en toute
indépendance et impartialité au service
de l'intérêt
général néanmoins la relance historique
de notre filière nucléaire exige de nous
que nous repensions et adaptions le
organisation de notre sûreté
nucléaire il est possible que ce texte
apporte une réponse concrète à cette
obligation et une partie du groupe RDSE
le pense et quoi qu'il en soit les
débats qu'il suscit sont essentiels
faire la démonstration de la sûreté d'un
système c'est d'abord le confronter au
doutes or le premier doute qui nous
tarode concerne les gains d'efficience
qui seraient apportés par la fusion on
comprend l'ambition
l'intention la volonté de construire une
autorité plus forte plus réactive mais
les anciens élus locaux de cette
hémicycle qui ont vécu tant de fusion de
collectivité savent bien que le
gigantisme n'est pas toujours synonyme
d'efficacité loin de là et puis derrière
la
fusion nul doute que ce cache des enjeux
de gouvernance qui mériteraient aussi
d'être posé sur la
table dans cette même logique de
clarification vous me permettrez de
louer les travaux effectués par les
rapporteurs en commission qui ont
cherché à préserver une distinction des
responsabilités entre expertise et
décision à renforcer l'expertise
indépendante par la consécration des
groupes permanents d'experts à garantir
un niveau de transparence élevé à
prévenir les conflits d'intérêts
notamment pour préserver les capacités
de recherche ainsi qu'à mieux associer
le Parlement et la société civile
toutefois ces apports de la Commission
ne risquet-il pas de créer tout
simplement un nouveau système bicéphale
une hydre à deux têtes à rechercher un
équilibre parfait entre d'une part
l'amélioration de l'efficience des
procédures et d'autre part le maintien
de notre sûreté nucléaire au niveau
d'exigence et de transparence le plus
élevé possible cette fusion prend tout
de même le risque d'entraîner une
désorganisation du fonctionnement de
deux organismes qui ont appris au fil
des années à travailler en bonne
intelligence d'ailleurs le calendrier de
ce projet de loi nous interpelle aussi
la fusion de différentes structures peut
déboucher sur un travail d'intég ration
administrative susceptible de durer des
années avons-nous des années à sacrifier
à une réorganisation alors que l'on
parle d'un horizon 2035 pour la mise en
route des premiers réacteurs de
technologie
PR2 chers collègues notre sentiment
c'est que en créant cette nouvelle
autorité on sait ce qu'on perd mais il
est difficile de savoir ce que l'on
gagne attention à ne pas ébranler un
système qui par sa dualité sa fiabilité
a tissé un véritable lien de confiance
avec les Français
pierre angulaire de l'acceptabilité
sociale du nucléaire et condition
cynéquanon sans laquelle la relance de
la filière ne pourrait pas se faire
comme cela a été dit par de nombreux
collègues il existe pourtant d'autres
alternatives à la nécessité de refondre
de la gouvernance de notre sûreté
nucléaire je pense ici à une
augmentation substantielle des
ressources de l'IRSN et de l'ASN pour
garantir leur soutenabilité sur le long
terme à la poursuite de l'effort
d'augmentation des moyens humains pour
ces deux entités tout en revoyant leur
politique de ressources humaines afin de
renforcer l'attractivité de leur métier
le nucléaire a un rôle clé à jouer dans
la politique énergétique française du
21e siècle pour renforcer la
souveraineté de la France ça a été dit
et pour répondre aux exigences d'une
énergie décarbonée pilotable et
disponible notre contrôle de la sûreté
nucléaire a permis de faire accepter
cette énergie auprès de nos
concitoyens je ne sais pas s'il faut
prendre le risque de sacrifier cette
confiance pour plus d'efficien
le groupe RDSE vous le savez est
toujours du côté du progrès et de la
simplification administrative mais
s'agissant de la sûreté nucléaire il
appelle à la vigilance et chacun votera
en son âme et conscience après nos
débats chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Nadj av pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants pour 7
minutes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame et monsieurs les
présidents de commission monsieur le
Président de l'Office messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues faire de
la France le premier des grands pays
industriels à sortir de sa dépendance
aux énergies fossiles tel est l'objectif
fixé celui-ci passera par la relance
historique de notre filière nucléaire ce
texte est donc primordial les 2/ers de
notre consommation d'énergie finale
émane encore aujourd'hui des énergies
fossiles nous devons accélérer la
décarbonation de notre pays et la
production massive d'énergie décarbonée
qu'elle soit nucléaire comme
renouvelable nous partageons tous ici un
objectif commun remettre nos pays notre
pays sur la bonne trajectoire
énergétique si l'on attend avec
impatience le projet de loi sur la
souveraineté énergétique la stratégie
française pour l'énergie et le climat
ainsi que les deux lois d'accélération
de l'année dernière sur les énergies
renouvelables et sur les nouvelles
installations nucléaires poursuivent un
même objectif produire plus
d'électricité décarboné pour faire face
aux besoins futur parce qu'une France
souveraine face aux instabilités
géopolitiques est une France qui
maîtrise sa production d'énergie comme
l'a rappelé RTE l'été dernier nous
devrons produire entre 580 et 640 tawh
supplémentaires d'ici 2035 pour assurer
l'ensemble des besoins en électricité
cette stratégie demande donc que nous
accélérions fortement sur les énergies
renouvelables et sur le nucléaire de
façon continue et de façon
structurelle je salue en ce sens la
création d'une délégation de programme
interministériel au nouveau nucléaire
les crédits d'investissement massif des
plans francerance et France 2030 la
tenue de Conseil de politique nucléaire
ainsi que les victoires acquises par le
volontarisme d'IER espanier runach avec
la nouvelle définition de la taxonomie
verte et l'alliance du nucléaire qui
permettent de mettre cette énergie au
cœur des politiques européennes comme
l'a souligné le gouvernement ces
derniers mois la relance du nucléaire
passera par la prolongation du parc
existant le développement de nouveaux
nucléaaires Français avec les PR2 et les
smmr et par de nouvelles solutions de
stockage des déchets alors que nous
n'avons développé qu'un seul pr depuis
19 ans cette relance du nucléaire va
demander une montée en charge et en
capacité inédite pour la filière depuis
le plan
Mesmer c'est un changement de paradig
complet qui requier un niveau de sûreté
optimal et un changer pour être réussi
et accepté par nos concitoyens il s'agit
aussi d'un enjeu industriel clé avec
100000 emplois à créer en 10 ans c'est
pourquoi réformer la gouvernance de
notre sûreté nucléaire aujourd'hui ne
nous semble pas dénué de sens ce projet
de loi fait suite à un premier débat
tenu ici même en début d'année lors de
l'examen du texte d'accélération du
nucléaire le groupe RDPI se félicite
d'une réflexion de le plus long terme
qui a pu voir lieu avec un rapport
parlementaire de l'OPEX et de nombreuses
consultations publiques menées avant la
présentation du projet de loi en conseil
des ministres afin d'assurer une pleine
maîtrise industrielle et des standards
de qualité et de sûreté au plus haut
niveau imaginable dans le contexte hors
norme qui a été rappelé le gouvernement
a fixé quatre objectifs qui sont autant
de principes qui devront guider l'examen
de ce texte l'amélioration de
l'efficience des procédures
l'indépendance de l'autorité vis-à-vis
des exploitants nucléaires et du
gouvernement une transparence renforcée
vis-à-vis du public l'amélioration de
l'attractivité des métiers pour garantir
à la nouvelle autorité de bénéficier de
compéten et d'expertise
d'excellence et il n'est pas inutile ici
de rappeler la responsabilité premier de
l'exploitant nous avons débuté en
commission l'examen du projet de loi
avec l'adoption de 57 amendements je
veux remercier les rapporteurs au fond
et pour avis pour leur
travail parmi ces modifications une
grande partie vise à apporter des
précisions qui répondent aux inquiétudes
exprimées notamment concernant la
séparation entre les activités
d'expertise et de décision au sein de la
future autorité ainsi que sur la
publication des avis d'expertise en
outre trois points nécessiteront une
attention particulière dans la double
problématique d'un calendrier contraint
et d'une activité
démultipliée le respect de l'engagement
d'un rattrapage des salaires des
salariés et contractuels publics
l'accompagnement des changements majeurs
dans les procédure de travail pour les
500 fonctionnaires et contractuels de
droit public de l'ASN et les plus de
1600 salariés de droit privé de l'IRSN
dans une configuration inédite pour une
autorité administrative indépendante la
mise en œuvre claire de dispositions
sociales qui figurent dans le projet de
loi notre Commission a également
introduit au sein de la future autorité
une commission d'éthique et de
déontologie composée de personnes
extérieur qualifié comme cela existe
actuellement pour l'IRSN
elle sera char chargé de conseil de
conseiller le collège pour la rédaction
de règlement intérieurs et d'en suivre
l'application et de prévenir les
conflits d'intérêts suivant encore une
recommandation de l'OPEX un amendement
déposé par les deux rapporteurs pérenise
aussi l'existence de groupes permanents
d'experts nommés en raison de leurs
compétences dont les modalités de
nomination resteront précisées dans le
règlement intérieur le groupe RDP vous
l'avez compris salue la plupart des
évolutions intervenu en commission et se
prononcera en faveur de ce texte je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Monsieur
Franck montoger pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
pour 3
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues malgré le
travail des rapporteurs que je salue ce
projet d'intégration de l'IRSN dans
l'ASN ne nous paraît pas suffisamment
fondé en raison son étude d'impact
faible
ne définit pas clairement les objectifs
s'agit-il d'aller plus vite de faire des
économies d'améliorer des processus
d'expertise et de décision on ne sait
pas s'agit-il de mieux communiquer avec
le public on ne le sait pas davantage et
les territoires expriment leur
inquiétude par la la voix de
l'Association nationale des clli le
rapport de l'opexte au demeurant de
bonnes factures informative et
pédagogique auquel il est fait souvent
référence comme s'il valait étude
d'impact n'en dit rien non plus la
fusion y est prise comme postule là qui
plusit le futur plan de charge annoncé
s'inscrit dans un cadre programmatique
non défini à ce jour toujours pas de PPE
le Titre 1 du projet de loi souveraineté
énergétique devait en traiter il a été
supprimé par le gouvernement à tel point
que le Conseil supérieur de
l'électricité unanime s'en est ému
officiellement dans sa séance du 25
janvier dernier en résumé on fait tout à
l'envers depuis le début et on persévère
à chaque occasion on travaille au coup
par coup sans perspective d'ensemble de
ne croyez-vous pas que le titre 2 de ce
projet de loi aurait dû être traité il y
a des mois dans le projet de loi de
relance du nucléaire plus grave la
perspective de développement de petits
réacteurs de le smmr stratégique pour la
décarbonation de l'industrie ne
devrait-elle pas être discuté dès
maintenant sur son volet sûreté et
radioprotection le plus incongru reste
sans doute l'absence d'un ministre avec
lequel pour le moins nous aurions pu
échanger quelle considération pour le
travail du Parlement et accessoirement
pour la démarche relative au sujet qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui sur le fond ce
projet de fusion fragilise ou remet en
question certains principes auxquels
nous sommes attachés le plus fondamental
est celui de l'indépendance du
scientifique qui nécessite une
séparation garantie entre expertise et
décision l'enjeu majeur c'est la
confiance pour toutes les parties
prenantes dont le grand public et il n'y
aura pas de confiance publique sans
transparence totale à cet égard de sur
cro les moyens financiers nécessaires à
l'augmentation de charges sont renvoyés
à un rapport quel perspective d'exercice
et d'évolution des métiers hautement
qualifiés concernés les personnels sont
inquiets nous n'avons pas de réponse à
toutes ces questions majeures nous
n'avons pas non plus de proposition
d'optimisation de l'organisation
existante évalué ou qui aurait dû être
évalué au regard d'objectifs qui sont il
faut le reconnaître peu ou ou pas
clairement formulé pour toutes ces
raisons de fond nous nous opposerons à
ce projet de loi cependant en
responsabilité et dans la continuité des
échanges que nous avons eu avec
l'Association nationale des CLIS et les
syndicats de personnel des deux
établissements nous proposerons des
amendements pour renforcer la sûreté et
la radiprotection en France je vous
remercie merci la parole est à monsieur
Guillaume chevrolier pour le groupe les
républicains pour 4
minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues les projets de
loi que nous examinons acte la fusion de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire et
l'Institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire au sein d'une autorité
unique de sûreté nucléaire et de
radioprotection ces textes visent à
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers
accroître la transparence du nouvel
organisme vis-à-vis du public et
garantir l'efficience de la sûreté
nucléaire
bien que technique ces dispositions sont
utiles et bienvenues pour accompagner la
relance du programme nucléaire civil
français que nous appelons de nos vœux
depuis plusieurs années au Sénat elle
s'inscrit dans le prolongement de la loi
nouveau nucléaire que nous avons voté en
juin dernier et qui doit permettre de
revenir sur les erreurs fatales commises
par le passé notamment en 1997 sous la
gauche pluriel lorsqu'a été abandonné le
surgénérateur super Phenix ou plus
récemment avec la fermeture de
Fessenheim pendant l'examen en
commission les rapporteurs que je salue
ont suggéré un certain nombre
d'ajustements qui fluidifi plus encore
les différentes procédures don notamment
les règles de commande publique
concernant les projets de recherche de
production et de stockage nucléaire ces
apports sénatoriaux qui s'inspirent des
recommandations de l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques
permettront de consolider véritablement
la nouvelle organisation de l'Autorité
de sûreté si nous sommes nombreux à à
souscrire pleinement à cette réforme je
souhaite néanmoins insister sur un
triple enjeu qui me paraît essentiel
celui de la formation de la compétence
et de l'attractivité des métiers de la
filière nucléaire cette réforme conforte
les moyens humains de l'Autorité de
sûreté nucléaire en la laissant plus
libre de redistribuer ses ressources
humaines entre les nouveaux projets
nucléaires et le nucléaire historique en
cela elle permettra sans aucun doute
d'accroître son efficacité et c'est une
très bonne chose mais gardons tout de
même à l'esprit que les contrôles
exercés par les équipes seront plus
nombreux rendant par conséquent la
charge de travail plus forte et posant
ainsi la question d'une éventuelle
dégradation du niveau de contrôle il
faudra donc rester vigilant à ce sujet
par ailleurs le projet de loi vise le
maintien du vivier de recrutement et
l'attractivité des métiers de la filière
il me paraît absolument essentiel
d'investir de larges moyens à cet effet
pour susciter l'évocation car la filière
nucléaire a trop longtemps été décriée
auprès de nos jeunes au moyen
d'arguments
fallacieux comme je le disais nous
voterons cette réforme car la majorité
sénatoriale défend depuis plusieurs
d'années avec force la relance du
nucléaire civil en 2021 nous avions déjà
adopté deux résolutions à ce sujet et
sur l'intégration de l'énergie nucléaire
à la taxonomie verte européenne la
mission d'information transpartisane sur
l'énergie nucléaire et l'hydrogène
bacarbone a également abondé en ce sens
il s'agit à présent de de tenir nos
objectifs à travers ces deux textes
amendés par la commission la gouvernance
de la sûreté nucléaire doit sortir
renforcé et gagner en cohérence en
efficacité et en lisibilité pour
susciter la confiance de tous cela est
une étape nécessaire si nous voulons
préserver notre indépendance énergétique
s'inscrire dans la lignée des plans
mesem mais aussi agir pour le climat et
dans l'intérêt bien sûr de nos
concitoyens de notre industrie que nous
devons décarboner de nos entreprises et
de nos collectivité locale je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Monsieur
Patrick Chauvet pour le groupe Union
centriste et pour 4
minutes madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame messieurs monsieurs les
présidents messieurs les rpporteurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues le 30
janvier dernier lors de sa déclaration
de politique général le Premier ministre
rappelit le caractère crucial du
nucléaire pour l'avenir énergétique de
notre pays et son indépendance si nous
voulons être à la hauteur de nos
ambitions nous devons agir à tous les
étages de la fusée de l'atome de
l'industrialisation jusqu'à la
supervision des activités en passant par
la formation la recherche et
l'innovation notre effort sera total ou
ne serura pas à ce titre ces projets de
loi sont une étape qu'il nous faut
saluer il nous ils nous doteront d'une
autorité moderne aux moyens financiers
juridiques et humains adaptés aux enjeux
contemporains ainsi avec le groupe Union
centriste nous saluons ce projet de
fusion de l'ASN et de l'IRSN qui
permettra de former la future asnr
frappé du coin du bon sens cette réforme
est la bienvenue c'est à ce titre que je
souhaite saluer le travail réalisé par
nos rapporteur Pascal Martin et Patrick
chaise qui ont permis de corriger
certaines malfaçons et d'enrichir ce
texte sur ce texte nos lignes rouges ont
été respectés les salariés des deux
entités bénéficieront des garanties
liées à leurs différents statuts de
droit public comme privé la diversité
des parcours sera une force de
l'institution deuxème point majeur les
garanties apportées en matière
d'indépendance de l'expertise nous
sommes pour partie être satisfaisant
notamment après les ajustements apportés
par nos commissions nous devons nous
appuyons nous appuyer sur une autorité
efficace pour lancer les chantiers
cruciaux du nucléaire mais également sur
une autorité de sûreté mettant
l'expertise et la rigueur scientifique
au cœur de son réacteur décisionnel
malgré cela des défis attendent la
future autorité à commencé par la
question de son attractivité 20 à 40 %
c'est la différence de revenu entre les
membres de la futur asnr et les salariés
des entreprises privées cette réforme ne
nous exonère pas de notre responsabilité
face à ce problème qui perdure que
proposez-vous pour améliorer
l'attractivité de ces métiers ce n'est
pas le seul point de vigilance de notre
groupe en effet si le texte va dans la
bonne direction la distinction entre les
missions doit être inscrite dans notre
droit et devrait être respecté dans les
faits nous devons pouvoir être les
garants de cette indépendance via un
contrôle rigoureux il en va de la
crédibilité des rapports de l'asnr
parallèlement nous rappelons de nos vœux
un meilleur encadrement des relations de
l' autorité avec les autres acteurs de
l'écosystème nucléaire à l'image deedf
les impératifs économiques ne doivent
pas prendre le pas sur la sûreté de nos
installations enfin le transfert de
l'expertise nucléaire de défense au
ministère des armées à tout de la fausse
bonne idée l'asnr doit garder cette
compétence dans son giron et s'appuyer
si nécessaire sur l'expertise des
services de l'État en matière de défense
vous le voyez monsieur le ministre nous
saluons la copie mais la rédaction reste
perfectible la gramère du nucléaire
mérite des des ajustements qui ne sont
pas de l'ordre de l'anecdote avec le
groupe usuc nous y veillerons je vous
remercie merci la parole est à Monsieur
François bonhomme pour le groupe les
républicains et pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mieur le rapporteur et
président ce projet de loi s'inscrit
dans le cadre d'une politique de
réhabilitation de l'énergie
électronucléaire en France et malgré
l'arrêt ça a été dit de super Phenix par
le gouvernement Jospin en 98 la pression
de nos voisin allemand au sein de
l'Union européenne pour favoriser les
seuls ENR malgré aussi les campagnes de
diabolisation des écologistes et enfin
malgré l'abandon des démonstrateurs
Astrid ou encore la fermeture de fon
bien sûr la filière malgré cela
nucléaire française doit renaître de ses
cendres après de multiples
tergiversations à term moment et il faut
le dire un revirement assez acrobatique
le président République a enfin donné
une direction lors de son discours de
bellefort en janvier 2022 faisant enfin
du nucléaire la pierre angulaire de
notre politique souveraine énergétique
le Parlement a depuis adopté la loi du
22 juin 2023 n nous apprêtons examiner
bientôt le futur projet de loi relatif à
la souveraineté énergétique dont la
déclinaison se fera au travers de nouve
plan pluannuel de l'énergie et de la
stratégie nationale bas carbone le nuclé
le nucléaire enfin y aura toute sa place
mais que de temps et de compétences
perdu durant ces 30 dernières années et
à quel prix celui de la fragilisation de
notre filière nucléire d'excellence ou
encore de l'importation d'électricité
carbonée dans le cadre de la nouvelle
donne le gouvernement prévoit donc une
réorganisation de la gouvernance et de
la sûreté nucléaire avec une fusion de
l'ASN et de l'IRSN le gouvernement a
bien essayé de passer en catéini par la
voie deux amendements à l'Assemblée
nationale dans le cadre du projet de loi
sur l'accélération des procédures de
construction de nouvelles installations
nucléaires cette tentative a logiquement
échoué tant le gouvernement avait baclé
son projet en ne menant pas en
profondeur les consultations nécessaires
aux parlementaires pour avoir un avis
éclairé fort opportunément ces derniers
ont alors saisi
l'opesque pour engager un vrai travail
de fond sur les conséquences d'une
éventuelle réorganisation de l'ASN et de
l'IRSN nos collègues fui et Piednoir ont
fait des propositions de créer une
grande autorité indépendante de la
sûreté et de la radioprotection dont les
moyens financiers et humains seraient
renforcés le gouvernement a pour sa part
mené une série de consultations auprès
des différentes institutions ces débats
n'ont pas donc été inutiles pour arriver
à un projet en tout cas plus mature sur
le fond comme le préconise lopeesque ce
projet vise à clarifier l'organisation
en regroupant des moyens humains et
financiers actuellement
alloué à la sûreté nucléaire et à la
radioprotection afin de mettre fin à une
certaine ambivalence à la matière et de
faire face au nouveau défi qui s'annonce
notamment par un renforcement des
capacités d'expertise de la nouvelle
entité la future acnr viendra donc
remplacer la SCN et se verra attribuer
des prérogatives de l'IRSN actuellement
en charge d'effectuer des recherches sur
les risques liés à la radioactivité
récemment le président de la SN a
apporté son soutien à cette fusion
clarificat
il a souligné que le dispositif actuel
n'a pas été conçu pour faire face à un
contrôle sûreté dans le contexte hors
norme issu de la relance de la filière
nucléaire française notamment avec la
poursuite de l'exploitation des
réacteurs existants la réation de
nouveaux réacteurs le stockage sursite
ou géologique du combustible et
l'installation de fabrication et de
retraitement du combustible le texte
vise ainsi à obtenir une une
organisation resserrée avec
l'institution d'un interlocuteur unique
l'unification du pilotage des priorités
le recroupement des compétences ou
encore la fluidité des processus
d'instruction sur un plan juridique le
projet de loi prévoit que la future pour
la future entité le maintien essentiel
d'un statut d'autorité administrative
indépendante il est cpendant regrettable
que la mention indépendante ne figure
pas dans la
dénomination notre collègue et
rapporteur Patrick chz a déposé en ce
sens un amendement qui va dans le sens
des recommandations du rapport de
l'opesque à propos de ce texte la
question centrale qui interroger
celle-ci avec cette nouvelle
organisation va-t-on comme l'affirme le
gouvernement concilier efficacement le
niveau de sûreté avec la montée en
charge des CNPE existant ou à venir le
niveau de sûreté dépendra bien
évidemment de l'efficience des procés de
contrôle comme le souligne le président
de la scène la réalisation de 6pr2 ainsi
que le développement des réacteurs Amr
et smmr pourrait mettre fin en mettre en
tension la chaîne d'approvisionnement de
la filière nucléaire dans ce contexte
une multip multiplication tion de
contrefaçon d'irrégularité ou de fraude
est alors à redouter il a rappelé aussi
que le contrôle à tous les niveaux de la
chaîne doit rester un point majeur de
vigilance pour toute la filière
laasn possède aussi ses propres
compétences techniques et même
d'expertise propre en revanche il est
vrai que le projet de loi prévoit que ce
soit le règlement intérieur qui fixe la
nature et les modalités de publication
des avis techniques en fonction de la
nature des dossiers des décisions
traitées par la CNR la nature documents
publics et le canancement temporel de
ces publications à ce sujet l'ANC
demander que le contenu du règlement
intérieur de la SNR répondre au
principes de transparence tel que
précise dans la Charte de
l'environnement merci chers collègu je
partage ce point de vue madame la
Présidente du point ainsi que celui du
collège des CLIS avec la plus grande
transparence publique de l'expertise
garante de la sité nucléaire merci de la
réussite de ce projet dépendra non non
je suis désolée je suis désolé donc le
maintien de cette confiance
deè Mame la présid
non la Sûreté Nucléaire merci beaucoup
merci
beaucoup merci la discussion générale
est close je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 21h40 pour la suite
de l'examen de ce texte la séance est
suspendue